Three two,
one.
Boom.
Michael Scharmer's here,
ladies and gentlemen again,
and we've been talking about silly
people for the past 15 minutes.
We just,
we had to get warmed up,
fill the list is endless to get warmed
up with body doubles.
It's fair as Hillary Hillary had her
about yet flat.
Earthers um,
forests aren't real.
Is that what they're saying?
Jamie?
The flat earthers we're going to talk
about the flat earthers for one reason.
Um,
the reason why I wanted to bring this up
is because I think there's a lot of
folks out there that are super gullible
and I think they're being trolled.
I think they're being trolled by people
who put together these,
it's one of two options.
Either they're being trolled by people
who put together these elaborate
arguments for something that they don't
believe because they're just trying to
make money off of youtube videos,
which is entirely possible.
And this needs to be thought of.
I mean really needs to be considered
because lou youtube videos can be
extremely lucrative if you can get a
youtube video with millions of hits and
a lot of these videos on all sorts of
different conspiracies and all sorts of
different crazy things can generate that
kind of volume.
You're making real money,
pennies on the dollar,
but if it's millions,
yes,
yep.
It starts becoming real money.
It starts and if you do a bunch of them
and you can,
you do them on a regular basis,
it becomes a Gig.
It becomes like what they do.
They create these silly videos,
but people who just don't have the time
or the inclination to actually read
scientific papers and articles and
journals and all these different things
that explain how we've known for a long
time that the earth is right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a myth that a Columbus proved that
the earth is not flat,
that it's round.
They,
the ancients knew,
the Greeks knew,
Columbus knew.
Everyone knew a little bit then that it
was round and there's absolutely
depictions on clay.
Right.
Drew it in clay.
They drew all the planets as circles,
right?
They knew,
right.
I mean there's some obvious simple ones
anybody could do.
If you see an eclipse,
like a lunar eclipse,
you can see the Earth's shadow on the
moon.
It's round.
Uh,
you know,
if you,
if you're high enough and you know,
the ships are sailing out,
you can see the mass does.
The last thing you would see as the
whole drops over the horizon first,
slowly.
You know,
there's things like that that we know
the earth is round.
You know,
you traveled around,
you come back to where you started.
Um,
you know,
now their explanation,
the flat earthers is that,
yeah,
it's round like a pizza,
but around flat pizza and all the
continents are on the one flat face side
up and that the satellites are up there
going around.
It's like,
yeah,
but the satellite photos don't show all
the continents in one picture because
some of them are on the other side of
the globe.
So that refutes that.
Well,
not only that,
but they think that satellites are
actually in planes.
They're in planes and Ortho over that
are just circling around.
There's no actual satellites.
They don't even believe in satellite.
The
lights.
Yeah.
So back to your original comment,
I,
some of these recent ones are so that
you can't help but think,
okay.
They don't believe that they're just
yanking our chain for maybe financial
reasons.
But that does get to the question I
always get,
which is do these people really believe
it?
The cult leaders,
the people that make a extraordinary
claims,
are they just making this stuff up?
You know,
people make shit up all the time.
It's called fiction fantasy.
Uh,
or do they really believe it or they,
you know,
true believers and you know,
it's hard to tell.
It's hard to get inside people's heads.
Uh,
the old flat earthers in the 19th
century,
I think they really did believe it.
Uh,
there wasn't much money to be made,
you know,
on those kinds of things.
I mentioned the Alfred Russell Wallace
who was the co discover of natural
selection with Darwin.
I wrote my dissertation on him.
And wrote a biography of him and he was
quite the colorful character who was so
open minded to new ideas that he was
also gullible.
So open minded enough to see this
radical new theory of the evolution of
life by natural selection that's good.
Pioneered other fields like biogeography
and so on.
But he also was really into spiritualism
and phrenology,
seances handling all that stuff.
And then he encountered an ad and one of
the natural history magazines for this
500 pound bet,
if anybody could prove the earth is
round.
So he devised a test and he went down to
the Bedford canal,
which is a long,
straight,
like 10,
10 kilometers long.
You can see the whole distance and if
you put these little sticks in the
ground with markers on them and you get
a little telescope like,
uh,
um,
surveyors scope and you line it up,
you can see that it bends.
So at each point that stick is,
you know,
three meters above the ground at each
point.
And uh,
but you can see that it's dropped down
in the last one,
so it's bent.
So he won the bet,
but he didn't get paid,
of course,
because these people are cranks.
And,
uh,
so we had to take him to court.
It's ended up costing him about 15 years
of his career,
you know,
just wasting time,
writing letters and getting court dates
and suing this guy and,
you know,
whatever the try to win the bet.
Yeah.
Just try to win the bet.
So,
and of course,
what happens,
you get caught up emotionally,
like,
I'm not going to let this bastard get
away with this.
You know,
you should have just cut his losses and
laugh.
But anyway,
and I found these letters that this guy
wrote to the national degree or the,
uh,
the Royal Geographical Society about,
Alfred Russell Wallace.
You know,
you have one member of your society that
should be,
you know,
he's a quack and a crank and,
and he wrote letters to the Wallace,
his wife,
you know,
you better not sleep in your bed at
night quietly because I'm coming to get
you guys.
And it's like,
oh,
look,
like death threats.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
it,
you know,
you're,
it's always questionable to deal with
cranks because some of them are a
little,
uh,
mentally deranged.
Sure.
And they can attach themselves to
someone like Wallace or Darwin or
anybody else.
If,
if you can somehow or another connect
yourself to them and some sort of an
argument,
it's kind of legitimizes you at least in
a way because that person's giving you
attention,
that person is engaging you and it
elevates your standing.
And then whenever two people are
arguing,
a certain amount of people are going to
choose sides.
They're just getting,
even if what you're saying doesn't make
any sense,
there's going to be a gang of people
that go,
I like,
what are you saying?
And they're going to join in and people
love,
they love to be on a team.
They love to be,
they want to be on team Wallace or team
crank.
Right.
That's a natural.
And that's also why people like a lot of
the creation is Wanda debate dawkins.
Yes.
Because he's the guy,
he's the number one top best known
biological scientists in the world,
possibly for since Darwin himself.
If I can get him onstage and it's
Dawkins likes to say,
this will look better on your resume
than mine,
so I'll pass and he doesn't need the
money.
So well in the contrary argument or the,
uh,
the other position is so many people who
are actual scientists want to debate
depok oh well yes.
And I have debated the puck and now,
so here's back to the question is does
he really believe it?
Cause people,
most skeptics and atheists thing,
well,
pucks just a fraud,
a con man selling snake oil.
I don't think so.
I've known him now for a number of years
and the last year I've spent a lot of
time with them.
And the reason I know he believes it,
absolutely what he says is because he's
always working on me.
Um,
privately,
you know,
if we're at lunch or dinner or,
I mean,
I got half a dozen emails just the last
two days from dupont.
And you know,
it's not for public consumption is not
trying to,
we're not debating,
he's just trying to convince me,
uh,
you know,
that he's right.
Like,
what does he try and convince you?
Well,
a about consciousness here.
Uh,
can you do it in his voice please?
A quote from Vince Donta,
all of the body is in the mind,
but not all of the mind is in the body.
A Swami Rama.
Well as long as he's quoting Swami Rama
and we know.
So,
uh,
so he sends me these not because he's,
he's a crank.
He,
he,
he wants to convince me that his
worldview is,
um,
different from mine but better or I
should have a more open mind.
Well,
that's a bizarre quote and that quote
can be interpreted a bunch of different
ways and um,
you know,
one could say that we really don't know
where consciousness is.
We,
well we need that exists in the mind.
But you know,
what we do know is if you blow someone's
brains out,
they no longer exhibit any behavior that
you could recognize as being conscious.
Right?
So,
um,
in my debates with the Puck,
I make the point,
I mean,
he points out as you just did,
consciousness is the so called heart
problem and not how neurons fire.
We know how that works,
but the experience you have of looking
at me and vice versa,
how does that derive from just a
dopamine going across synapses or
norepinephrine going across synapses?
It's just electric meat.
How do you get electric meet to have
this experience where happy as he likes
to say,
where's the red?
If I open your skull up,
there's no red in there,
there's no room in there.
It's just neurons firing.
So how does that happen?
Okay,
so this is the hard problem.
No one knows,
you know,
but,
but it's not that we don't nothing,
you know,
we have some ideas about how it works
and I think this is just one of those
ones that either will never be resolved,
like free will,
determinism,
you know,
okay,
we live in a determined universe.
How can we have free will if that's
true.
Okay.
The words,
the language that,
you know,
there's certain restrictions on our
cognition of how we think about the
world and that's very much influenced by
the words we use.
So that could be one of those mysterion
mysteries that you know,
can't be solved simply by the,
not that we're not smart enough,
that just the limitations of how we
perceive the world.
Uh,
and it's just,
uh,
you know,
so there,
I like to look at like this,
there was a big survey of professional
philosophers done about three years ago,
about 2,600
phd,
either professors or,
or doctoral students in philosophy.
What is your position on,
and they're like 25 different debates in
philosophy and like free will.
Determinism,
it was roughly equally split between
determinist and compatible is like Dan
Dennett is a compatiblist.
Sam Harris is a determinist and a small
percentage of a libertarian free will.
What are the compatiblist compatiblist
uh,
except the,
the premise that the universe is
determined governed by laws of nature
and so on,
but that,
um,
we make free choices within the causal
net of the universe.
That is,
I'm making choices like I chose to come
out here.
Uh,
and that was a choice.
yes,
the universe is determined,
but my behavior,
my actions might volitional choices
within the net.
The causal net is part of it.
Uh,
and in any case,
you can't know all the variables so it
feels like you're making free choices.
So you are in essence making free
choices because it feels free even if
cause you don't know all the determining
factors.
So the compatiblist is something like
that.
There's just different versions of it.
Dan,
it makes a good argument.
Degrees of freedom.
We have this idea of degrees of freedom
and engineering.
Certain systems are more complex or less
complex in certain systems have more
variation than others.
So if you think of degrees of freedom,
like an insect has very few degrees of
freedom,
it's almost entirely instinctively
driven.
Small number of neurons and so on.
Uh,
maybe a rat has more degrees of freedom
than an insect that dog more than a rat
primate more than a dog.
US more than the other primates.
It just how many choices,
how many variations.
So you can come up here,
you go this way,
this way,
this way with the human,
it's not clear which way they're going
to go with the Rad.
It's more predictable.
They'll take this,
uh,
this maze or that maze because the food
is over there.
Something like that.
So as dented argues that we're free
year,
then,
you know,
the,
the mouse or the dog,
we have more choices.
And even within human populations,
the law has already accommodated this.
So,
you know,
first degree murder is different than
second degree murder.
Oh,
you know,
w w what is the difference?
To what extent you intended to kill the
person you planned it out versus you are
out of control.
You know,
you inflict grotto,
you Katra partner in bed with somebody
else,
you lost your temper ban.
Oh,
okay.
But you wouldn't normally do that.
So we think,
well,
violent aggressiveness or drug
addiction,
alcohol addiction,
the tumor on the brain.
Uh,
you know,
the famous case of a,
the University of Texas Bell Tower
shooter,
uh,
Whitman,
you know,
you left that note.
Uh,
you know,
lately I've been feeling not normal and
I'm feeling quite violent and I'm going
to do some bad shit today.
So when I'm dead do an autopsy.
So he went out and killed his mother and
then he went to the bell tower and
killed 19 people or whatever it was.
They did an autopsy shirt off.
He's got a tumor.
I think it was next to the hypothalamus.
So we would,
we would recognize,
look at that guy had fewer degrees of
freedom than you and I do.
Uh,
it's not that we,
excuse it,
we just say,
okay,
he had a tumor,
you know,
so that's the compatiblist argument.
I'll sand someone like Samara
determinist would say it's,
it's all,
it's all tumors,
you know,
it's all determined.
You're just using different causal
vectors to describe the behavior.
Some of them are more obvious than
others.
So the best argument on that case I know
of is from a guy named Adrian Raine,
who's a psychiatrist and neuroscientists
who was the first to scan the brains of
a serial killers in prison.
So he would take this portable fm Ri
brain scanner to these prisons and these
guys have nothing to do.
So they're happy to participate as
subjects.
And he would scan their brains and he
found that they have very little self
control,
which is associated with the prefrontal
cortex and their prefrontal cortex is
we're pretty quiet,
pretty undeveloped,
inactive.
So you have all these impulses that
bubble up and there's no break.
There's no governor on the system to
keep it in check.
Whereas you and I would count to 10 or
walk out of the room if we're getting
heated up,
uh,
their lucky more likely to just reach
out,
punch you if you say something,
you know,
like something like that lack of self
control.
So he argues that,
um,
that if somebody has a tumor,
it's obvious you can see it.
But what if somebody just has the
crappiest background?
You can imagine,
you know,
raised in a broken home,
single mom,
drug addictions,
gang related inner city,
crappy diets dropped on their head and
so on.
And he gives an example of this,
a young man named Donta page and African
American who was convicted for raping
and killing a woman and he's on death
row or I think he got life in prison in
a case.
Um,
you know,
so he describes spends pages in this
book,
the anatomy of violence,
of this guy's background.
And it's the worst background you,
you could possibly imagine that surely
has affects on his brain.
So there's not a tumor you can't scan
and go,
look,
there's a tumor,
okay,
he's got a tumor,
but he's had a background that would
surely be different than the background
you and I have had.
And therefore he had fewer choices in
his actions that you and I would have.
And so,
you know,
the law would deal with that
differently.
And,
but see,
someone like Dan Dennett would say,
well that those are degrees of freedom.
He had fewer choices than the person
that didn't have the awful background.
So that's one of these,
this is one of those things where it
depends what you mean by these words,
like decrees of freedom,
volition,
choice actions versus just more of a
physics,
engineering billiard table type of
causal model.
Well,
it's a really complex question and
subject and one that people battle with.
Even when you're faced with the
determinism argument like you,
you,
if you take in the logic of determinism,
like you are the product of your
genetics,
of your environment,
of all your life experiences have all
these different things and they are
what's dictating all your choices.
So even when you're making a choice,
the choice you're making is based on all
the data that you've taken in your
entire life.
So do you in fact have freewill at that
moment or has it all been sort of
determined by all these experiences?
And it's so hard to argue because
everybody's life is different.
Everybody's take on things are
different.
Everybody's experience.
You could have the exact same experience
as I do,
but your take from it might be very
different than mine.
You might be a person meditates.
So you might be really into mindfulness
and really into uh,
sitting down and trying to objectively
analyze all your thoughts and your
reactions.
You might come out with a completely
different decision based on that.
So is it still determinism if all of a
sudden you start practicing meditation
and you change your behavior?
Is that determinism?
There is that I would love,
I would love that more into the category
of freedom.
You,
you,
you may become self aware.
Like I have a violent temper and I
really need to do something about this.
Well,
what can I do?
meditation,
right?
Uh,
okay,
so then I choose to start meditating.
Just like the attic.
I mean,
we talk about addicts having been out of
control,
but lots of addicts actually stop.
They break the addiction they have,
how do they do it?
Well,
meditation,
they used,
you know,
behave cognitive behavior therapy.
They go to these clinics and so on,
but they've got to drive themselves
there.
They got to actively do it.
They're aware that they're doing that.
I would lump that into the,
you're making kind of a free choice.
You don't have to do that.
You could just keep doing your
addiction.
But if I was a determinism proponent,
I would say,
well no,
because your decision to make that
choice is based on all of your
experiences,
your genetics,
your,
your family,
your background,
all of your input that you've gotten
from other people about your behavior.
And you've decided to make a choice
based on that data.
Correct.
That,
that,
that would be the counter give very
daunting.
But yes.
So it's like that.
I think also with consciousness,
you know,
what do you mean by consciousness?
And you know,
it's a hard problem.
Okay,
but,
but is it ever resolvable?
So Depok thinks it's not just through a
neuroscience explanation,
bottom up molecules scaling up,
emergent property,
mind out of brain.
That's what most of us scientists think.
People like Christof Koch Works on this
problem.
You know,
he's scaling up,
he's just looking at the visual cortex
in the back of the brain and looking at
visual conscious experiences.
Now let's see if we can figure that out.
So I liked that approach.
But someone like Deepak says,
it'll never get us there.
That that he,
so he used language like the
consciousness is the ground of being.
Now I know that phrase from Paul Tillich
who said God is the ground of being,
what does this mean?
It's,
it's like,
it's not quite to say that consciousness
is everywhere.
It's in here,
it's in the clock.
It's in this table because that would be
more of a sort of a deism or pantheism
or something like that.
It's,
it's more like it's just a part of the
universe.
I'm not sure.
I really understand cause you know
deepak has a different language,
has that sort of that eastern wisdom
traditions like romy and so on and very
kind.
I will call it word salad.
Well there's a lot of word salad going
on.
Sounds like that to westerners.
I've tried to put myself into his
worldview.
So for example,
a few months ago my wife and I went and
spent three days at the Chopra Center
that the La Costa resort and spa in
Carlsbad,
California.
Okay.
This is a great weekend.
And we did the full immersion,
the t,
the Diet,
the yoga,
meditation,
the whole thing.
And I did feel much better afterwards.
But of course,
you can't go to the Lacosta spa and
resort in Carlsbad,
California at the beach and not feel
good.
I mean,
if you don't feel good after that,
you're the problem,
not the system.
It's also the things you're saying.
You're drinking tea,
which is great for you doing yoga,
which is great for you.
You're relaxing and that you're also
going there with the intent to try to
make some positive change in your life
and try to get on a good path.
That's right.
And all those things that good,
all those things are good.
Now,
um,
Deepak just released a paper that was
published this week.
He wasn't one of the authors,
but it was on the effects of,
of his program on biomarkers and various
physiological changes.
So this was conducted by a Harvard
medical scientist named Rudy Tanzi.
Rudy is the scientist who discovered the
genes for Alzheimer's.
So he does a lot of work with Alzheimer
patients.
Uh,
you know,
to what extent do we have any meds to
treat it?
Not really.
Um,
what about meditation?
What about diet?
These kinds of things.
You know,
there's,
it's not terribly hopeful,
but you know,
maybe some,
some of these supplements,
who knows.
But anyway,
he wanted to know what are the effects
of meditation?
I just regular people,
so they went to the La Costa resort and
spa.
There's already a six day program that
the tow percent of runs with its
Ayervetic,
but it's,
it's yoga,
it's meditation,
it's flowed diet,
massage,
not massage.
And this particular one,
although they'd have great massages
there too,
which is also healthy.
And um,
and so what they found was that,
and so they compared a vacationers who
were just staying there at the resort.
They took all their various biological
markers to novice meditators.
They taught them right there.
This is it.
Day One,
here's what we do.
Go through it in 20 minutes and 30
minutes.
And so it meditation,
Yoga,
and then a group of people that were
already there that were serious daily
Meditators,
they've been doing it their whole lives.
Right?
So there was a difference.
Okay.
First of all,
everybody got better.
Your blood pressure goes down,
stress hormones are practically zero.
And all these great markers,
including the vacationers.
Then they found a difference between the
vacationers and the meditation group.
So the claim is that you could go on
vacation,
but you can't do that every day of your
life,
but you can meditate everyday of your
life.
So the effects of meditation may be
something like you can do it at home.
Uh,
the relaxation,
the meditation,
the focus,
you know,
whatever you call that focus thought,
uh,
on your mantra.
A actually cha has physiological
changes,
one of which was affecting Beta
amyloids,
which are the kit,
the chemicals that cause the plaques and
tangles in neurons that cause
Alzheimer's.
So Rudy's argument was that it could be,
there's sort of a causal chain there
that that meditation leads to less
stress,
less inflammation,
and therefore less of these buildup
plaques and tangles around the neurons.
That kills him.
Cause that's what happens in
Alzheimer's.
Your brain just dies,
neurons die.
So amongst various factors that might be
effective,
meditation may work.
Now someone like Sam who does meditation
with,
he would look for a causal chain,
you know,
from the bottom up.
What are the,
you know,
the effects of having certain thoughts
in one part of your brain affects a
different part of your brain and that
causes neuro chemical,
hormonal changes.
And so on.
Deep Buck,
of course,
wants to use a different argument and
say it has to do with mind that not,
not brain,
but mind consciousness that's out there.
But,
but even saying it's out there is not
correct,
but any guys that,
it doesn't matter what the worldview
differences are,
uh,
in terms of does it work?
If it works,
who cares?
You know,
this would be good if,
and people that meditate,
even people that aren't sort of new agey
or,
or eastern religious,
uh,
they say it works.
Uh,
I haven't done it.
My,
I don't do it myself and I do other
things that I think are relaxing,
but,
um,
but if it works,
who cares what the explanation is
initially.
Um,
it'd be nice to know something that's
effective.
So it turns out from this new study just
published in nature,
uh,
that meditation seems to be effective
for these biomarkers,
including telomers.
It increases telomerased race,
which causes the telomeres at the end of
your chromosomes to either stay the same
length or to grow a little bit.
And that has direct relations to aging
because we know that the hayflick limit
on the number of times a cell can divide
and when you get get to that upper
ceiling,
then the cells are dead.
And that's what causes aging ultimately
is genetics.
So if there was a way to sort of slow
down the process of the telomere ease,
degrading,
maybe through the production of more
Tele Marie's chemicals that co you know,
effects that,
then if meditation is one of those or
diet whenever that would be a good
thing.
So down we'll do,
they determine that from studying the
exact same person and studying them
premeditation in post meditation and
studying the rate the telomeres start to
decline.
But there's particular study,
it was just uh,
uh,
the control group versus the
experimental group,
the meditators versus non-meditators and
the vacationers and how,
but how much of c,
it seems to me that that's something
that you would want to study over a long
period of time.
And then you would,
you would have actually have to study
the person over a long period of time
before they're meditating to really get
a base.
I don't know if anyone's done that yet.
Um,
but that would,
that would be good.
Yes,
we need,
we need more scientists themselves.
Rudy and his team said,
well,
we have to replicate this.
You know,
it's just a one shot deal here six days
at a resort.
That was it.
We got to do more of this.
But the point is that,
um,
you know,
surely there is some value in some of
these techniques,
whatever you call it,
you know,
so take the word salad out and stop
using words like ground of being or
whatever.
Forget that.
Just consciousness.
You know,
there's,
there's a certain like way of talking
that people really enjoy hearing because
it makes it sound like,
oh,
there's some sort of a mystical
explanation and solution to all of the
problems that modern day society
presents you with.
And you could find those through this
course or this lecture or this book or
this practice.
I am now engaging in a practice that
separates me from the stresses of the
modern life.
But I think that what you're saying
about meditation and other things that
you do that relax you,
I think it's very important to relax.
And I think we all know that.
And that's one of the real problems with
our world,
our society today,
especially in America,
is so go,
go,
go that.
It's like if you are an athlete and you
train constantly,
one of the most important things is
recovery.
It's a critical aspect of athleticism.
And if you just train and you don't
recover,
your body breaks down,
you're red lining your system and you're
not giving your system the proper time
to recover.
I think that when you meditate,
and for me,
my big one is a sensory deprivation
tank.
I have one in my basement and I go in
and all the time,
and it's the most relaxing thing in the
world because you're going in there,
the water's the same temperature as your
body.
It's amazing.
And in doing that,
I feel like that is,
uh,
there's no motion at all.
I'm concentrating completely on my
breathing until I achieve this certain
state of consciousness that I get to
when I go in there.
And the way I get to it is just
concentrating entirely on breathing in
and breathing out.
And I just think about in with the good
and out with the bad and in with the
good and,
and that's what my only thoughts that I
try to maintain.
Other thoughts get in there.
They bounce around and they ricochet out
and eventually they stop existing.
So it is meditation,
it's a meditation,
but I think any form of just right,
just give your body a chance to give
your heart rate,
a chance to drop,
give your mind
a chance to slow its revolutions per
minute.
Just give yourself some time to recover.
And then also reflection.
Give yourself some time to consider the
momentum of your life.
Because I think that is also a real
issue with people is that your life sort
of starts taking over you and your
actions and your,
your the things that you do during the
day.
A lot of them would get based on the
momentum of the things you've already
done versus what you actually want to
do.
Right.
And it just kind of gets out of hand and
you don't have a chance to step back and
look at it and go,
I got to stop doing that,
or I need to do more of this,
or I have to figure a way to not do,
you know,
all these things together.
You know,
whatever the decision you make.
But those decisions come out of
reflection,
which comes out of space away from the
actual thing and time and thought,
right.
My Jewish friends telling me that this
is what the Sabbath is for Friday night,
sundown til Saturday.
Sun Sundown makes sense.
That's a time of,
you know,
family,
friends,
reflection,
no TV,
no,
you're off social media,
you know,
and all that stuff.
That makes sense.
I mean it's a smart thing and that's an
old tradition.
So you know,
yes.
Set by eight.
Even my Jewish friends are not
religious.
It's just a cultural thing and that it,
that's probably a good thing now where
it gets a little out of hand.
I think I like another one of my full
emergence for my chapter on De puck and
eastern religious traditions of my next
book.
Heavens on earth.
Uh,
we went to see depok and t eckart Toley
who did a show at the shrine auditorium
in Los Angeles.
The power of now,
the power of now this guy,
I mean this place,
what a,
it must have been 3000 people,
4,000
people there,
uh,
paid 50 bucks a head or,
I mean it,
it was like wow.
All right.
And deep hot cache.
Yes.
I don't know what it costs to rent the,
the shrine,
but those are expensive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you know,
the two of them just sort of walked up
and down the stage and just talked and
uh,
hundreds knows.
Yes.
It's a very much like that.
And you know,
the people that attend these are fairly
well off people.
You can sort of tell them the parking
lot how they're dressed.
Same thing with,
uh,
this last weekend I was at the sages and
scientists conference at Depok puts on
every year this year instead of at this,
uh,
at the La Costa resort,
it was at the Beverly Wilshire.
Okay.
So there's a lot of people from La that
are depok fans and they go,
you know,
these are not your normal run of the
mill folks.
You know,
these are people that,
you know,
upper middleclass,
good looking well off driving nice cars.
I don't know if you've ever been to the
Beverly Wilshire,
but if you sit at the,
there's a little bar,
um,
it's uh,
uh,
Wolfgang puck's bar and you know,
so they have good German beer,
which my wife and I liked,
cause she's in Germany and we just sit
there.
The,
when I watch these cars pull up,
you know,
Ferrari,
Lamborghini,
Rolls Royce Bentley,
and it's like,
okay,
this is not a,
one of my caltech events,
you know,
with science geeks coming,
it's,
it's a different audience.
So I do wonder the people that are in
that particular study that Rudy Tanzi
did,
this is not a randomly picked sample
from the general population.
You know,
who knows,
they have different kinds of problems or
issues,
you know,
a lot of them.
Depression,
mental,
you know,
things that might be affected by
psychological states anyway.
You know,
it's different from the physiological
changes they,
they mark but still,
uh,
but when you go,
we watched the shrine auditorium thing
with Eckhart Tolle and he's very
effective.
You know,
he speaks in a manner,
I can't even imitate it.
It's just very soft,
very slow.
I could almost feel myself like melting
into the chair like Ah,
if not,
it is very hypnotic.
Yep.
Have you ever been hypnotized?
I have.
Yup.
That's what it feels like.
Right?
Yeah.
So he is probably doing,
yeah,
he's bringing the audience to a certain
state of thinking and I'm sure it is
effective for the now and you know,
technically he and d bucher right.
That there really is only the,
now you know,
about the three seconds or so of the
current state of before,
after the past.
And before the PR future,
it's just it,
you know,
and even your memories of the past,
it's just neurons firing in your brain
now of what happened in the past and the
future is really,
it hasn't happened yet,
but it's just your neurons firing in
anticipation of what might happen.
So they're right.
It really,
they all the action is now,
you know,
of course as I like to joke a,
my three days joe percent or at the,
um,
uh,
at the,
at the new age place up in big Sur,
uh,
um,
what's that?
Uh,
the one on the right on the cliffs,
the Isilon Institute that had been there
several times and it's super relaxing
and you know,
but uh,
the now ends on Monday morning and to go
back to work,
you know,
my,
my mortgage has a now coming up pretty
soon called the payment and you know,
I don't know to what extent you can live
in that condition all of the time,
but if you take it in moderation,
like,
like you said,
just once in a while to step back once a
week,
once a day,
whatever.
For 10 minutes,
half an hour,
hour deprivation tank once a day.
Something that seems pretty reasonable.
Yeah,
very reasonable and very beneficial.
I think those people that you're talking
about,
they do have a whole different set of
problems because they have achieved
material wealth beyond the imagination
of the average person.
If you're pulling up in a Ferrari,
you're essentially pulling up in a
house.
You're driving a house around,
you're driving a 200 plus thousand
dollar automobile,
which to most people,
it's just crazy like that someone could
have one of those.
So that kind of a person who isn't happy
is the type of person that wants to go
to some sort of a seminar by a health
guru.
Oh,
look at that Blue Lamborghini.
I mean,
this thing is too much.
Those things will break down the two
folks,
right?
If you're gonna invest,
that's not the move Bahrain,
there's probably some oem oil money
here.
I was at,
um,
one of the hotels in Beverly Hills.
I had dinner there and um,
this [inaudible]
pulled in.
It was a more than a million dollars and
a,
I think they're like one point,
what didn't we look it up like 1.3,
it doesn't matter one point $3 million
or something like that,
but it had the Saudi Arabian plates on
it and uh,
it actually had palace plates.
It said something palace on it.
So this was some royal person sent his
car over either in a boat or on a plane
and uh,
there was,
you know,
that car and then there's a million of
these other super expensive luxury cars
all over the place.
Those people have their own problems and
we would like the average person who
works all day and has a pile of bills
and has all this debt is like,
God damn it.
I would love to be a rich person.
How the hell these fucking rich people
still have problems?
It doesn't make any sense.
But you get used to your life,
you get used to your life and if your
life is being an indigenous person and
living in Bolivia and the jungle and you
shoot spears at fish and that's how you
get by.
If that's what you,
you get used to that life,
that life becomes your life and you find
problems and maybe you don't find as
many when you were in a hunter gatherer
tribe as you do,
if you're a some sort of a hedge fund
manager who's just on adderall every
day,
it's completely stressed out and your
wife driving you crazy and your mistress
wants you to leave your wife and you
don't know how the fuck you got yourself
into this situation and,
and then you decide I'm going to go to
this power of now seminar and
straightened my shit out.
Right.
Pull up in your Blue Ferrari.
And it's like there's problems.
People create problems and just because
someone has material wealth,
not only does it not eliminate problems,
it creates a whole new slew of problems
that would lead to the kind of self
indulgent sort of exploration of your
condition that these things sort of in
force and
cater to.
Yup.
So you got to go back to work the next
day or whatever.
But another point I made in my talk for
deep,
by the way,
there,
there he is with the fam,
you know,
super,
Super Nice Guy.
I'm sure he really does,
guys,
guy.
Uh,
but um,
like,
um,
if you go to one of these workshops and
you feel much better,
so there's been a few studies,
not many like,
uh,
big corporations hire people like Tony
Robbins to come in and,
you know,
give the Spiel to,
they get the salesforce,
I'll fire it up.
And they are,
they are fired up near as we can tell
the,
you know,
the effect lasts for a couple of weeks.
They go back,
they're hitting the phones are making
those calls or making more money.
It's like,
it's work,
but,
and then it tapers and they're right
back to where they were motherfuckers.
So this is why,
uh,
we published a study on this and skeptic
that the number one predictor of anybody
that would buy one of those books,
self help books or go to the seminars
are people that have already done so.
And they do an over and over and over.
So in a way,
if it worked,
why do you have to keep buying the books
and the tapes and the,
and the going to the seminars and maybe
it only works for just a little while.
Well,
have you ever heard of it?
The expression
that inspiration is like bathing.
It's very effective,
but it must be practiced on a regular
basis.
Right?
Well that's,
that could be it.
I think it is.
You know,
so there's,
there's two senses in,
does it work,
does it work for you personally?
Uh,
and then does it work for everybody?
So the scientists,
the scientists want to know is not that
you personally feel better when you went
to the La Casa spa and resort for three
days of,
of course,
I'm sure you did,
but can we actually measure the
differences and then apply that to
anybody?
Uh,
and not just that resort,
but any resort or is it like,
you know,
60% of the people between ages of 25 and
40 that have these medical conditions or
whatever,
when we apply that technique,
you know,
40% of the time they'll get better.
You know,
that's really what we want to know.
So on,
on the one hand,
you know,
somebody says,
I went to detox place,
I felt better.
I'm glad that they felt,
you know,
the world's a little bit better place if
you feel better.
Okay.
From a scientist perspective,
like yeah,
that's interesting,
but does it really work?
Not just placebo or not just temporary.
It's like a Netflix just released that
documentary based on um,
Tony Robbins and the film is called,
I am not your guru,
but clearly watching this,
this is what everybody thinks.
That's my girl who they want to be like
him.
And he has this hypnotic effect on the
audience.
It's incredible.
I've never seen anything like it,
but the question is when they go home a
week later,
two weeks later,
did it make any difference?
I mean,
I'm sure they feel better there.
Tony Robbins says a lot of really good
stuff and he says a lot of really
motivational things that I listened to
and I was like,
this guy's making a lot of sense.
I bet he does a lot of people,
a lot of good.
What I always ask is what has he done
other than do these seminars?
Yeah.
You know,
like he's become really effective in
motivating people.
But what has he done other than motivate
people,
right?
I mean he's,
he produced anything other than these
books that are designed to motivate
people.
It's like,
I really appreciate what he does and I
don't want to belittle it because I read
a lot of his stuff back when I was
competing in martial arts and when I was
starting out as a standup comedian,
I read a lot of his stuff,
you know,
and it motivated me and it gave me some
good,
good things to think about that.
I think I was already sort of on a self
improvement path and I was trying to
take in a lot of information from a lot
of different places,
including dianetics.
I bought it dianetics book and they
hounded me for 10 years.
You're on the list.
Heck,
I ordered it late night on one of those
things.
But I think it's interesting what he's
done because it's not like,
like say if a guy like steve jobs or you
know,
a Wazniak who created apple,
if they made a book on how to get
motivated and get something done,
and here's the core core aspects of
success in this endeavor.
And I've done this and I want you to
know this,
I want to spread this knowledge,
but when a guy is just motivating
people,
right?
I'm always like,
like I know a guy who just motivates
people and he's a terrible comedian and
he's just decided to start motivating
people now.
And I'm like,
well,
what the fuck going on here?
But,
but meanwhile people buy it because
people love that feeling.
They love that feeling of someone saying
something that makes sense,
that gets them going.
Yeah,
I'm going to eat plant based and I'm
going to go jogging every day and I'm
doing yoga four times a week and I'm
going to drink only water and I'm going
to,
you know,
and then one day they passed by Krispy
Kreme in that hot.
It's a lot of fresh sign is on those hot
doughnuts.
You get one of those glazed hot babies
in your system.
Yeah.
Thing,
you know,
they're having a coffee and they throw
sugar and it fuck it.
Already have the sugar and the donut.
Coffee tastes better with sugar.
You hope it's better than the little
joke about,
you know,
the guy who took an ad out in the
newspaper says,
send me a dollar.
I'll tell you how to make $1 million,
run an ad in a newspaper and said you,
he's better than that.
Of course is a great collector of
philosophical points that really can
affect you if you absorb them.
I think what you pointed out about the
amount of people that get involved in
these things that don't actually have
any longterm change in their life.
I think what it's like is like Rehab.
You know,
my friend Chris Bell who made this
recent documentary,
prescription thugs and he made bigger,
stronger,
faster that documentary on steroids.
Really cool guy.
Um,
and it was really fascinating is he went
through making this documentary
prescription thugs,
and then in the process of it had a
pretty significant injury that got him
on pain pills and then he got hooked on
pain pills for himself while he's doing
a documentary on pharmaceutical drugs
being highly addictive.
Yeah.
He went to this rehab and when he came
on the podcast and was discussing the
rehabilitation process for getting off
these pills,
one of the most important aspects was
how much time it takes and how you have
to be fully immersed in this idea of
recovery for a long period of time to do
it in this method to,
to in order to enact any real change.
And I think that's probably the same
thing with motivational speakers.
I think you can get that initial burst
where somebody could slap you and go,
Hey Mike,
I'm taking these fucking pills away from
you,
man.
You can't keep taking these things.
You're hooked.
You're like,
you're right,
man.
You're right.
I got to change.
So this is both burst of motivation.
You're a good man.
You're a smart guy.
You're too smart for these pills.
You're right,
you're right,
you're right.
You get that feeling.
You wake up the next day and you'd go
jog and you get a good sweat and you'd
go and you'd get some wheat grass juice
and you power that down.
You're like,
I'm on the path.
But then the inspiration dies off and
you so comfortably slide back into your
old ways.
So I think these motivational speeches
by Anthony Robbins or any of these
people that I think they can be
beneficial.
But I think for most people,
the comfort of their old path is such a
magnet.
Their compass just just goes towards
that magnet.
It's almost like they needed every day
for like
a year or two years.
Three years.
Yeah.
Something already Tansy from Harvard
tells me for a normal habit,
it takes about 60 days,
couple of two months,
every single day of retraining the brain
on a new habit.
And that's just a regular habit,
like drinking coffee or just what time
you get up in the morning or whatever
exercise.
Uh,
so I suspect with drugs or alcohol,
it's probably a year or two to really
completely re retrain your brain,
rewire the neurons,
literally,
uh,
to,
to change that habit.
It's doable.
People do it.
Uh,
it's just,
it can be very difficult.
So I think part of the appeal of the,
the self help groups,
so called self help gurus is that you
keep going because you need the,
you know,
there's sort of retrain reminder every
six months or you listen to the tapes
once a day or once a week.
Uh,
and it just kind of keeps the new habit
reinforced.
Probably literally dopamine hits from
hearing the voice of the person and
someone like Tony Robins,
I mean he's just,
I've met him at Ted.
He's just bigger than life.
I mean he's like six,
eight huge hands and deep voice and just
talks.
Wonderful.
He's got a great presence.
And uh,
he's quite the opposite of Vec are
totally,
I mean he comes out in the stage and the
music and the lights,
right side kicks,
boom.
Thrown this out.
Yeah.
And it's like,
oh,
words and shit cause kicks it boards.
But in the film,
this documentary is really quite
revealing and it's called a,
I'm not your guru.
It opens with him talking to this young
man.
He's,
I think he's German and he looks Super
Sad.
He's what with Bob?
What's,
what's bugging you man?
Stand up.
It's bugging you,
you know,
and it's like,
I'm feeling suicidal.
It's as soon as he seen us in front of a
large group of calling is 3000 people in
this hotel room,
cameras and lights.
Jesus,
he's going to Powell and he'll,
well,
it was a little bit like that,
but it's completely different way.
He said,
uh,
he looks down,
he says,
is it the,
is it the red shoes?
He goes,
what is it?
You're red.
Those are the fucking red issues I have
ever seen.
May those are fucking red shoes,
dude.
And the camera goes,
Daddy,
he's got these red shoes and this.
And the way he says it is so funny.
This guy just starts laughing and Tony
Goes,
don't you be laughing now because you're
going to spoil the program for suicide.
I mean,
come on.
And the,
and then he just kind of worked on him
a,
you know,
why are you feeling this?
And before you knew it,
this guy was,
you know,
he seemed like he was doing much better
awareness as I pulled out a gun and blew
his brains out on the stage.
The shoes.
I don't think that would've made the
film.
But the problem with that and another
story they show in there is,
is there's no followup.
We,
I have no idea this guy does.
He had another one with a woman who had
weight issues or something and
emotional.
Is it your relationship you're in?
Yes.
You know,
he,
he's kind of fit.
Like doctor Laurie,
he's figured out after all these years,
you know,
your problem number seven years is
number six.
There's only like 10 things that covers
90% of anybody that would come,
you know,
these are the,
and a,
so he hones in on its relationship.
Not Happy.
You love him,
but
you don't really want to be with him
forever.
Yes.
That's it.
Get your phone out,
but call him right now and it,
whoa.
There's like,
Holy Shit.
She's Dr.
Laura Anthony Robbins.
This is Tony in the,
in the film he says Tony Robbins.
Yeah.
So she calls the guy and he's at work or
something.
He's like,
yeah,
what's up honey?
Now I know I,
this is going to be really hard.
But in front of 3000 people in the chat,
she dumps him on the phone.
Oh,
fucking Christ.
You know,
this guy is like,
uh,
where are you again?
I'm here at the hotel.
Oh,
click,
dial tone.
You know,
and then Tony says you did the right
thing.
Okay.
So the question is,
but how could you make that call not
knowing anything about that person's
past and not knowing their behavior
patterns,
not knowing?
Well,
I mean,
who is she when she's on that stage in
front of 3000 people?
Is She really herself?
Right?
Because most people aren't.
No,
no,
of course not.
So you know,
I immediately want to know is,
you know,
two days later,
I'm really sorry.
That seems incredibly irresponsible to
get someone to break to have so little
information and to take someone on their
word at that moment.
Like there's some people that the one
day for whatever reason,
they'll go,
you know what,
I can't fucking do this anymore.
I need to get out of my marriage.
And they'll go to the bar and they'll
have a drink and they'll get crazy for
like a few minutes or an hour or
whatever.
And then they'll drive home,
they'll listen to a song and then their
wife,
we'll send them a text and then they'll
go,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Right?
Like why did I think that?
Why am I this?
And then you realize like you were just
indulging a certain pattern of behavior.
So how does he know that that woman
wasn't indulging a certain pattern or
behavior?
He does it.
He can't possibly know.
On the other hand,
may be she's really,
really stuck and maybe it was really a
good idea,
but he doesn't know.
That's right.
He might,
he might have given her awesome advice,
but he fucking for sure didn't know that
it was awesome advice.
Right,
right,
right.
And that's the problem with all these
programs,
like,
like Aa in a,
does it work?
They don't collect data or if they do,
they don't make it public.
We can't get the data.
How many,
what percentage of people that come and
last this many weeks or months and what
percentage never take a drink or take
one drink or whatever.
We don't know.
No one knows.
I was,
we have at the anecdotes like I went and
worked for me.
I went didn't work for me.
Well which is it wasn't there a recent
study on Aa where they were determining
that people who,
who leave the pro,
I try to find out if you see if you
could find it.
But it was a,
it was a recent study that was talking
about sobriety and maintaining sobriety
and how little of an impact than it
actually had.
It did have an impact on people
maintaining sobriety and they think that
that impact may have been connected to
the sort of sponsor system that they
have and not wanting to disappoint
people and camaraderie that you develop
in that sobriety environment,
which makes a lot of sense.
And I think it's really a clever how
they've structured it in that way.
Cause I think like having a mentor,
having someone's already done it.
Right.
And then also I think a big part
of what leads people to alcoholism
besides,
you know,
the genetic markers and all the
different things where people have like
an inclination to do it is um,
they,
there's,
they're trying to medicate themselves.
They're trying to,
and one of the things is they're trying
to medicate themselves from a lack of
companionship or lack of good,
meaningful interaction with people.
And when you're,
you're,
you're situation is on the line and sort
of a dire way like,
hey man,
you hit fucking rock bottom.
We're throwing this booze and the trash
and you're getting your shit together.
You're going to fall a 12 step program
now and you're going to do all it.
Now all sudden there's some urgency
involved.
And you have someone who you're
accountable to.
You have to call this person,
you're going getting a chip,
you know,
hey,
I'm 90 days,
congratulations.
You made it to 90 days.
And then you go up there and give a
speech.
So you get all this attention,
which people said desperately crave.
You get to be on a podium,
everyone's looking at you.
There's a lot involved in it that's not
just about sobriety,
about ritual,
social,
very social,
very social and it,
and it could be that works.
They've,
they figured it out over the decades.
That's definitely got something right.
But there was uh,
the,
the thing that was stuck,
the study was showing how little of an
effect it is a,
it's a really kind of amazing,
it does have an effect,
but the effect is not that much
different than people that just quit.
Like I've known a couple people that are
not involved in any sort of 12 step
program.
Like my good Buddy Greg Fitzsimmons,
he and I have been friends for something
like 27 or 28 years.
We met as rookie standup comedians.
We started like within a week of each
other.
And when I met him,
he was 22,
I believe at the time.
And he had just quit drinking.
He realized like his parents had issues
with substance abuse.
And as a young man,
he's like,
look,
I can't fucking do this.
I'm like,
I'm getting hammered all the time and
obviously I got the bug,
whatever it is,
I'm done.
Right.
And never drank again right here.
Like literally never drank again.
His whole life to this day hasn't dried
and is super successful.
Emmy Award winning writer,
all these people will still tell him,
you know,
you need to get an a program,
right because you're an alcohol ride
drunk.
This is the disease model of alcoholism
that's bothersome because it's really a
behavioral choice or behavioral problem.
But if you treat it like a disease that
the debt,
the good side of that is that it got
people off the,
you're just weak willed.
Um,
you know,
and you just,
that's your product.
Don't know it isn't bad,
but it isn't.
It isn't like cancer either.
Like,
oh I'm sorry you got cancer.
I'm sorry you have the alcoholic gene or
whatever.
Cause clearly like your friend and
there's a lot of people like that that
just quit.
They are able to do it.
And also from the scientific
perspective,
we don't have much data because we don't
know who they are.
Right.
They just quit.
They don't go through a program and then
we have them in our database and we know
what they did and how long they came and
so on.
Again,
does it work?
The only way to know is to really get
more data on this.
And we just don't have enough,
you know,
from those kinds of groups that do that.
Like Aa,
there are
academics who,
scientists who study addiction,
you know,
and they,
they tell me that,
you know,
the,
for the addict to take a single drink,
what's the harm?
Just to have a drink.
You're at the bar,
social,
whatever,
that it's much harder for them to not
have the second,
third,
fourth and they go till they pass out.
Whereas I never drink till I pass out,
uh,
in a long time anyway,
since college.
Uh,
but I,
it's like the determinism issue for me,
it's not an,
it's not a problem.
It's not a self control problem.
Uh,
but for the addict,
apparently the,
the brain is rewired and they,
it's much harder for them to stop.
Have that second drink.
Isn't it rewiring thing or is it a
genetic predisposition?
Boeing.
It's both.
Yeah,
it's probably a,
a plethora of variables,
right?
The contribute only the native American
population,
uh,
the,
the genetics are such that they have a,
a stronger alcoholism problem,
which is exasperated by the poverty and
you know,
all the other social issues that go with
that and on these reservations and it
makes it even worse.
But apparently there is a genetic
component.
I would like to know if that's true
because I remember this discussion being
brought up before with someone else and
then I looked it up and I found
something that had showed contrary
evidence,
but oh,
okay.
Anecdotally,
sort of everybody who knows that story
knows that native.
That's what we've always been told.
Yeah.
Native Americans didn't have alcohol and
their history and like there was,
um,
and I could be wrong on that.
I haven't looked at that,
any of that data in decades.
So they could be old material now.
Well,
jeans most certainly do get affected by
Diet and climate and where people evolve
and we're where their ancestors came
from.
There's,
there was a study,
um,
today,
what did I put?
I tweeted something today that made
sense why some people can follow a Vegan
Diet and be healthy in regards to Omega
threes is that if you come from a long
line of people who have followed a
predominantly vegetarian diet over the
course of over a hundred years or so,
the genetics start to evolve or change
and adapt to his diet to the point where
your body produces more omega threes
from different things.
It was real recently.
Um,
I,
uh,
I tweeted it this afternoon or retweeted
it.
The troublesome thing about Aa is,
is the religious component,
not so much you,
you have to believe in God.
No,
no,
no.
That's why they should supplement with
it.
It's more recent than that.
Did I see something about Omega threes
may not be as healthy as we thought.
We believe that.
I'd never know what that tank,
I don't have enough time.
Science keeps changing.
She keeps that you're supposed to
believe in a higher power for aa to
work,
but that year,
uh,
in a much,
much more insidious way,
I think you're a,
you're like a sinner.
You were an original center.
You are an alcoholic.
Say it.
I'm an ally.
I,
my name is Michael and I'm an alcoholic.
It's like the born again.
Uh,
I'm a sinner.
I was born
sinful,
but I accept Jesus.
Wouldn't it be better to say in my name
is Michael Shermer and I am a free man.
I liked him.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not trapped by any sort of a drug or
alcohol that would be more empowering.
Seems way better.
And that would be the Tony Robbins
approach.
You can change it.
So it's thrown sidekicks and shit.
If you just see the thing that happened
with Tony Robbins recently where they
had one of those coal walk firewall,
but these assholes were taking selfies
while they were firewalking and they put
their feet.
Yeah,
I can't believe he's still does the
fireworks.
You know,
cause it's a little risky.
I've done it twice.
We did it once for a Fox TV show.
And first of all,
we had a hard time finding any place to
do it.
But you did it as a skeptic to prove.
Explain.
Well explain the whole I wanted,
first of all,
I wonder what the experience is like.
And then second,
what is the explanation?
Why?
Why is it your feet don't get burnt?
Like in one of the shows we actually
strapped raw steaks to my feet and you
know,
and then walked across the coals and you
the stakes didn't get burned if you just
walk quickly enough.
So either dead meat is conscious and
thinking positive thoughts or it has
nothing to do with positive thoughts.
Didn't get cooked at all.
No,
no.
Because if you move fairly quickly that
the conductance of the heat is very slow
with wood.
So the analogy is this,
you put your turn the oven up to 450
degrees and you put a cake in and you
let it sit there for a while.
You open the pay and you put your hand
in the air is 450 degrees,
but you don't get burnt.
You touch the cake and it's 450 degrees.
You don't get burnt.
But you touch the cake pan or the the
metal part of the oven and you're burnt
almost instantly.
The temperature is all the same.
It's the heat conductivity.
That is how quickly a material Trans
Duce as heat from,
from it to you,
which is why we cook on steel versus the
actual Cole's themselves.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Because the Cole's or a poor conductor
of heat,
uh,
so if you,
okay,
but the PR,
the thing with firewalking is this,
you won't get burned if the bed is
about,
uh,
no longer than about 10 to 15 feet.
Eight feet is better and you have maybe
a flat of grass that's wet on either
side so that you're,
the temperature of the bottom of your
feet is a little bit cooler and then you
traipse across,
don't stop to take selfies,
big mistakes.
Uh,
but if you go above 15 to 20 feet,
uh,
the heat's going to start to build up
and there you can get burned.
So my guess is what happened with was
his people is,
it was a short,
probably a short bed,
but,
but probably they,
they didn't scoot across fairly quickly.
The two times I did it,
it was an eight foot bed.
You know,
I didn't mess around.
Man.
I just plowed right across.
It's very anxiety,
you know?
Is there a fun there?
Yeah,
these people are so silly.
If you Google Michael Shermer fire walk,
there's a video that's a very short
little firewatch,
very short.
And to the see the flames on the side,
they put wood on there after it's burned
for hours and hours,
and then they put,
um,
like cooking.
So at the flames
are coming up.
So from it from an angle,
it makes it look like you're almost
walking through the flames,
which you're not what,
it's sort of in some ways,
like kind of a rite of passage,
that passage or something.
It's like,
it's,
it's what you're doing is like a
ritualistic thing.
I feel like I'm,
it's a metaphor.
It's a metaphor for accomplishing
things.
Yes.
It really doesn't mean anything.
Well,
the problem is when,
you know what you just said,
now that metaphor is not going to
fucking work anymore.
So he just ruined all of this stuff is
all the people that could have possibly
gotten over the hump.
Now that you've ruined it,
Michael Shermer,
how dare you?
Yep.
So,
uh,
well,
I mean,
we want to know how does it work?
Right.
You know,
and I said,
if he had a bed of metal,
you know,
no one would,
could walk on it.
Not,
not even Tony Robbins,
no matter how positive he was thinking.
So dead wood coals is a poor conductor
of heat.
That's it.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
That makes a ton of sense.
That's why,
you know,
when you have a grill,
you put the coals down and then you put
that steel grate over the grill steels
and excellent ends up through.
Yeah.
And that's why we choose certain metals
as well to cook in.
You know,
it's,
I'm amazed he could get insurance for
this because people do get burned.
And the ones we did,
uh,
some of the people,
other people had little blisters because
you know,
if you've,
if you've walked slowly or you have 10,
you know,
I'd go beg for it a lot.
So I have pretty good callouses on the
bottom of my feet.
But if you don't,
you know that then your skin is thinner
and it's temperature builds up faster
for that and you're quite likely to get
the blisters,
especially if you get pedicures and
you'd put moisture on your,
yeah,
you're always like fear a tenderfoot.
Literally that's going to be a
tenderfoot.
That's right.
That was the cub scout thing,
right?
Tender foot and the beginning.
That's hilarious.
What a hilarious way to describe it.
With all these things,
you know it,
all things in moderation.
It's the extreme isn't it?
Gets people in trouble.
You know?
It's like you can never have a drink,
you can never have a piece of meat.
You can never do this or that and that.
And then when you go off the wagon,
so to speak,
then if you feel like a sinner and it's
back to that religious thing,
you know,
sin,
you're a bad person and that adds too
many,
I think,
negative emotional elements to behavior.
Then you're connecting all of these
ideologies to your behavior that are
very constrictive and very constricting,
and you're not allowed to deviate from
these plans and then you become a part
of this sort of team,
right?
Like the people that are in crossfit.
You ever,
have you ever met a crossfit person?
I know the shots,
the workout of the day,
right?
And it's positive.
They're in shape,
they look,
but they look crazy.
Like they can't wait to go back and do
chin ups.
Right.
Do they get out of their mind?
And it's a very beneficial thing.
Don't get me wrong,
but there's a thing that people do when
they get a part of a team or a group or
you're,
you're one of those now,
you know,
hey,
I'm a,
I'm an ultra marathon runner right now.
And like,
I'm in that group.
That's right.
Yep.
I just reviewed this book for The Wall
Street Journal and Cross fit training
and what it means to be fit now versus
when I was in my twenties say,
and uh,
you know,
back when Nautilus was,
the idea was you're going to isolate the
muscle groups.
Everybody's like,
yeah,
that's good.
Isolate the muscle groups.
So there's authors line,
why is that good?
Whoever where,
how did it ever get established that
isolating the muscle group is a good
thing and he shows that you know,
free weights,
you're using all of your body,
every muscle tendon,
just the balance and the move and all
that stuff.
It's much better.
But then I more,
I looked into it,
I thought,
well of course this is when high
schools,
it started introducing physical educate.
You got to go in the gym,
everybody's in the gym.
You can't turn loose thousands of
teenage kids and free weight rooms and
not have injuries.
So the Nautilus machine,
that was the solution to isolate and no
one's going to get hurt.
You can turn loose,
somebody does,
you can't clean and jerk a big weight
and not have somebody explained how to
do it without getting hurt.
Yeah,
that's certainly true.
But I think the big aspect of it was
people like to make things more
complicated than they need to be.
Or they always like to invent some new
way to do things and sometimes that new
way to do things looks awesome.
Like a Nautilus machine,
right?
I mean they have the big cam system and
there's tables and you get to the
plates,
you put the pin in the plate and you get
to move it up and down and it's all
right.
I mean it looks amazing,
but as far as like it being beneficial
to promoting functional strength is not
nearly as good as those like Olympic
lifts that people do like clean and
press.
But those are not that glamorous.
You know?
Those machines are very glamorous.
You know,
you could,
you could tell people that you're
pulling the whole stack.
Look,
I've got the whole stack,
right.
It'd be those isolating movements at one
point in time were thought to be the
best way to develop muscle because
they're really good for bodybuilding,
you know?
But there's a difference between like
when someone looks really good,
like there's certain looks that you can
achieve like giant biceps,
right?
Where they're completely out of balance
but they didn't have like a little knack
and they have no legs.
It's not,
it's not healthy,
but they want big biceps so they just
keep constantly doing referrals.
So you can get like really out of whack
doing those sorts of exercises if you're
not careful.
But if you want to be a bodybuilder,
that was always the protocol.
Like if you look at how Arnold lifted
now a lot of these Franco Columbo,
guys like they were all in isolation
exercises,
a lot of different,
they did a lot of tricep extensions,
they did a lot of things to pump those
muscles up.
They did,
you know,
squats and leg presses and stuff too.
But a lot of it was involving like
hitting specific muscle groups to
accentuate those,
you know?
But it's just wasn't the way to go.
But people for a long time thought those
machines were the shit they were like,
this is,
this is my cell,
Lucian.
And my review,
I wrote about this guy I met back in the
80s when I get into bike racing,
name filled grenache Shya.
He was Mister California bodybuilder.
Um,
in 1954 the year I was born and three of
the 50s and early sixties,
he was,
you know,
just lifting weights.
Mr Bodybuilder,
many Mehta cyclists and said,
well,
why don't you cut in San Francisco when
she come out,
got the Sunday ride going up in the
local hills.
Oh I'm going to kick their ass.
Kicked your ass,
said he got dropped at the first hill,
they're gone.
And you realize,
wait a minute,
maybe I'm not fit.
You know,
he was mister t nine Miss California
yet,
but also Mr fitness or the most fit
person in California.
So you realize I'm not fit.
I got no cardiovascular.
So that's,
he took up cycling and so on.
But um,
you know,
so this crossfit book,
it was that these people are more
balanced.
That was the idea,
I guess.
Cause you don't even know what you're
going to do for the competition.
Right.
You show up and it could be any one of
these different tasks so you have to be
more well rounded.
Well as opposed to I can lift this one
particular noddle is wait,
I read something about crossfit taking a
critical role in our society that if
there was a comparison to crossfit and
religion and they were saying that
essentially as people become more
secular and they move away from
religion,
they gravitate towards things like
crossfit.
They give him this sort of sense of
community and shared experience and uh,
like uncommon shared experience because
the average person you go to work and
you got cows that are bleeding.
Yeah.
Did my workout of the day to day.
Like just something like separates Mike
from the pack as he passes the break
room.
Like Mike's fucking crazy doing chin ups
every morning at 6:00
AM when a bunch of other assholes down
on supple va at the crossfit center and
you,
you get this feeling like I belong to
this group of unusual people doing
unusual things and it's a social
process.
And also that's,
well that's what religions do and you
know,
it's,
it's our group here and we're meeting
once a week or whatever,
and we had these rituals.
It's all like that.
They're very attractive to people.
Those things vary.
There's a book called Bowling alone,
uh,
by sociologists that it sort of tracking
the decline of social things like
bullying,
bully leagues,
you know,
very many bowling leagues anymore.
But more and more things like that were
more isolated.
We do our own thing and your computer at
home or whatever,
and that this is actually,
it's a good thing to get out there and
have a community,
but as always,
you know,
it's the extremism that,
I'm going to do this six hours a day,
easy.
This guy failed.
We're now,
she ended up dying.
He ended up dying early because he just
worked out like eight hours a day.
He keeled over dead in his gym.
I don't know what the cause is.
Christ.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
I mean it's like God he used,
he had this workout routine that he had
a like a $5,000
challenge that anybody that could match
him for the 45 minute workout routine in
his home gym and Olympic cyclist would
come and all these super steadily guys
and no one ever made it cause it was so
specialized for just what he does.
You know,
like one arm chin ups or you know,
one arm pushups or you know,
the stairmaster.
He built his own stair master before
anyone had stair masters and he would
just,
you know,
just crank it up at such a high level
that you just can't do it.
And that's all he did.
Was He fit,
you know,
was he healthy fit?
I don't know.
Well up to the point where your dad,
yeah,
that's probably an argument for once you
die from it.
I know you're probably not doing it
right.
We used to ride around Orange County and
he'd go see that lady out there Sunday
morning getting her papers,
cigarette,
coffee,
donut.
She's going to check out early.
You.
Oh,
that chick's probably still pissing on
his grave.
There's only so much we can do.
She shows up every morning.
I just reviewed this a,
another book for Wall Street Journal
called why men age about aging.
What we know,
and we know a lot,
but there's,
there's also know there's a lot.
There's only so much you can do.
You know that.
Why is it just men?
Uh,
the guy was teeth.
He's a doc who treats men for Jesus.
There's also a big difference.
Well,
there are some differences,
but I think there's,
I think from a marketing perspective,
if there's already a bunch of books up
for women on aging,
there's not much about men.
But that was it.
It doesn't,
it doesn't really matter because it's
really all the same process.
Ultimately,
your telomers we'll get you and the idea
of,
well,
we live twice as long as our ancestors
did a century ago,
you know?
Yeah,
that's true.
But really no one's living above 120
just more and more people are pushing up
to the upper ceiling because of public
health and just general stuff we do that
makes us healthier.
But in terms of longevity and aging,
you can't stop it as you can do is kind
of hopefully slow it down a little bit
and you want to have a higher quality of
life the further up you go as opposed to
lying in bed with tubes for the last 10
years of your life or something like
that.
So that was,
that's where the future research is,
where the breakthroughs will come.
Not,
not radical life extension lists that
I've also written about.
You know,
we're going to have 500 years there.
Schermer don't you want to live 500
years?
Like look,
just get me to 90 without Alzheimer's
and cancer.
Okay,
let's just start one decade at a time.
It just easy,
you know,
because you know,
the problems are really complex.
I think the quality of life thing that
you mentioned is one of the most
important things.
Like I have this phrase that I've said
many times,
but I'm gonna say it cause it fits right
here.
We all love to sleep,
but everyone's afraid to die.
We love to shut off,
we love to shut off at night.
Everybody loves it.
And we look forward to it.
But that one big shutoff when you're not
coming back is just too fucked up.
It's just too much.
Well,
here it's thing,
it's inevitable.
This is my,
in my next book,
I have a chapter called,
uh,
afterlife for atheists.
So these are not just the radical life
extension is,
but the p the mine up loaders and,
and so,
you know,
you're going to scan your connectome,
put it in a computer,
and then you know,
you'll wake up in the computer like
Johnny Depp in that,
here's the problem.
When you go to sleep,
then you wake up tomorrow,
maybe you're groggy for a few minutes,
but then you're,
you're,
you're back.
You still feel like you,
there's a continuity between today and
tomorrow or you get general anesthesia
surgery.
You wake up,
you're groggy or for a little bit
longer,
but the continuity comes back.
It's still you.
So the question is,
is if you're,
you die and we have a scan of your
connectome and we put it in a computer
and turn it on.
Are you going to wake up in the computer
like you did from sleep then?
I don't think so.
I think it would just be a copy of your,
if this could ever be done,
which is very unlikely because it's
super hard problem,
but let's just say it could.
Um,
I think there's a break in continuity
from death.
You're dead.
That's it and this thing we have is a
copy of you.
It would be like if we cloned your body
and then you die and then we reconstruct
the body and there you are.
That's not you.
Not first person through the eyes.
Me,
it's just a copy of me,
devil's advocate.
If I was going to play devil's advocate
to that,
what I would say is with our current
understanding and abilities right now,
you're correct.
However,
whatever we have right now,
whatever we are right now,
if we can understand it down to the
subatomic particles,
if we can literally go understand you as
a person like you as you stand right
here,
September 15th,
2016 if we can understand every single
aspect of you,
including consciousness,
we're not there yet.
Obviously there's a lot of debates and
does a lot of the struggles,
but we're looking at it in terms of what
our current understanding is.
If we looked at it in terms of the
understanding of people that lived in
the year 100 and it would be a
completely different idea of
possibilities,
like our possibilities today are
incredibly expensive in comparison to
people that lived in 1776.
Just the idea of what we,
what we understand about what it means
when you talk about atoms,
molecules.
Uh,
the,
the idea of Telenor is all these,
uh,
all the knowledge that we have today.
Imagine that expanding exponentially for
the next 500 a thousand years,
it's entirely possible that if we get to
that point,
we can recreate reality to a point where
I have a theory about people and it's
composed this completely unqualified and
don't listen to me,
but I think it's entirely possible that,
you know how bees make honey.
I think people might make the universe.
I think it's entirely possible that the
way the universe makes itself,
it makes a person,
it makes a monkey.
The monkey eventually figures out how
to,
a way to not get eaten by leopards and
the smart ones become a monkey.
And then they figure out shelter and
then they figured out agriculture and
then they really get going.
And once they really get going,
what they start doing is creating
technology that wait in the form of a
wheel on the form of a bucket to carry
the water so they don't have to keep
drinking out of the river and getting
crocodiles and fucking Giardia and
everybody's dying from in inborn
disease.
We figure things out slowly but surely.
And along the way they make better and
better things until they develop
computers,
until they develop artificial
intelligence to make something that can
think for itself.
And then they put that thing to work and
that thing gets better in two weeks than
thousand years of human development.
Right.
And I think that thing probably is how
the universe gets created that the
universe,
like this idea that the universe has no
beginning and no end,
that it's his infinite cycle of maybe,
and maybe it does that through people,
maybe it makes people and in our through
through intelligence of some kind,
some sort of intelligence.
But what we currently understand and
know of the known universe,
we're the only ones that we know of and
we're looking at what we're doing.
They're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What are we doing?
Like what are we,
where are we going with this?
We can just going to keep going.
Like when Elon Musk start talking about
artificial intelligence,
who's one of the most important and
popular and famous technology
enthusiasts starts talking about
artificial intelligence being summoning
the demon.
I mean that's how he described it.
We can be summoning the demon.
I really think that might be what we do.
I think we're getting caught up in the
Kardashians and we're looking at it
who's got a fake but and you know,
are those chem trails in the sky?
And I'm in a 12 step program,
I'm fucking crossfit.
And meanwhile what we're doing is we're
given birth to some new form of
transcendent technology that literally
rewires reality itself.
Yup.
Well that is an actual theory.
Uh,
you know,
the,
that we're living in the matrix that
it's all a computer simulation and it's
equivalent of a holodeck somewhere.
But I don't even know if we was so real
there.
If it was so really you couldn't
distinguish between the holiday of world
you're in and this world,
then how would you know?
So it really becomes one of these
thought experiments that's fine to
contemplate,
but how would you test it to see if it
was true or not?
And so the,
uh,
what do you pulling up there?
Just googled his name and ai.
And this came up from yesterday.
Let's talk about neural lace.
Oh,
well this is,
you know,
Kurzweil has been talking about this for
a long time.
You know,
the singularity really will come about
with a fusion between human intelligence
and artificial intelligence for people
who listen and read the,
uh,
the title there.
Jamie,
what does it say in there?
Scroll up.
Elon musk hints that neural lace project
to fuse ai with the human brain.
Well,
in a way,
a cochlear implant.
We just said Cook.
Do you know what that means?
Cochlear cut means now we'll,
we'll go over that another time.
Oh,
it's a new insults on the Internet.
A cook.
Yeah.
See you.
Okay.
See,
you see Kay.
Okay.
So let's cut and fuck.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
in some ways,
but it's,
it's,
it started off with cuckold.
Oh,
right.
Which was men who want other men to
steal their women and have sex with
them.
And then somehow or another,
it became an insult.
A that it seems to have a bunch of
different meanings,
but it's fun to use because it's new.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Uh,
uh,
I'm,
I'm hosting a,
one of our sites,
the conservative insult of the mountain
explained.
That's a cook serve explicit.
Let's pull that down.
We need to know what the explanation is.
Hmm.
redstate.com
blah blah blah daily car.
Oh,
I serve it live.
Yeah.
See cuckold is just when you're,
you've been cheated on tech serve it.
Iv.
Okay.
Port men do.
Yeah.
It's just a fun,
it's not real,
it's just a fun,
but it's interesting because,
uh,
certain,
you know,
four letter words,
curse words,
uh,
that they have certain characteristics
of the words themselves that are,
tend to be short and kind of guttural,
um,
abrupt.
You know,
fuck cut shit.
It's on.
And,
and there's a book coming out called
what,
what the F uh,
Benjamin Bergen is a linguist at uc San
Diego and he's coming up to do our
science alon in a few weeks.
And,
and so the idea is that certain words
trigger more sort of deep emotional
parts of the brain and the limbic system
and so on.
They're associated with bodily a flew
via,
you know,
feces,
sperm and so on.
It's just,
it's all this kind of crass,
basic cumins.
Cause the idea is to,
you want to hurt somebody with your
words emotionally.
And by associating it with the,
you know,
sort of a deep part of the brain that's
associated with really deep emotional
things that that's the theory is there
is like a tale about why curse words are
what they are.
You know,
why certain words are just,
they're not insulting.
They're just kind of funny.
Funky.
Yeah.
K.
Dot.
Right.
So any with a knee,
you know,
that's just not gonna.
It's too sweet.
Yeah,
right.
It's like a,
like a nice nickname for a friend,
so I'm not surprised at all that that
work is what it is.
Yeah.
It makes perfect sense.
Just based on the structure I didn't
fuck or the ticket.
These are two of the worst things you
could say to somebody.
That's why cock is so popular because it
seems like,
wow,
I think we got a new one.
It has that sort of feel and surprise
that it's conservative and cuckold
instead of what I thought it was.
That's just a new one.
That's a new one that they're adding to
the word cock.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's a,
well,
to make the Oxford English dictionary,
it has to be used like a certain number
of times and in secondary and tertiary
sources in a year.
Oh well it's done then.
It's in for sure 100% yeah.
The Internet is just the amount of data
that gets,
what's the figure about how much data
gets pushed on the Internet in a day
that I think it's the short amount of
time,
I forget what the window is,
but in that time,
more data gets passed in,
in,
in the entirety of human history.
That's a,
that was at the beginning of Peter
Diamandis,
his book on,
uh,
the,
the rapid growth of technology.
Um,
it's some insane was like every month
now.
It's the equivalent of all everything
that's ever been printed in the history
of humanity.
I don't have to look,
it's just a huge number.
It's just think about that and then
think about how many books Ron Hubbard
must've written this.
L Ron Hubbard wrote more books than
anyone who's ever lived.
You know,
if you got to the scientology around the
world,
they all have a room with his desk.
And a writing pad.
It's like,
it's literally like this Casey comes
back,
Tom B l Ron comes stumbling through the
door with rotten clothes and skins
hanging off of his bones and time to
write.
This chart shows what is done on the
Internet every minute.
Right?
Wow.
He's 16.
So it's got snapchat at the top with 6
million 94040004444.
Google.
Google is the most but owned by 10 fold
more than snapchat,
which is kind of crazy.
But that's just translating words.
These are different things that are
happening.
Right.
How many different interactions?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That is fucking crazy.
So I mean if he would carry out your
argument,
you know,
it's just only a matter of time before,
uh,
you know,
sort of that singularity is reached.
And then,
uh,
I mean,
one argument for the singularity,
you create the virtual reality that's
indistinguishable.
It's just a,
yeah,
you just need enough data.
It's really an engineering problem and
time.
But the question would still be in that
world.
Would you feel like you right now
through the eyes?
First person experiencing why not me?
Why not?
I don't know.
Uh,
I'm not sure that it would.
I'm not,
I'm not sure either.
I mean,
I kind of see the cryonics argument
because it being chronically frozen and
waken up,
woken up again.
If you could make that happen,
that seems like fall asleep.
Wake up,
anesthesia,
wake up chronically frozen,
wake up.
It's feels to me like it's the same mark
of the flora in your thinking is
consciousness is not in your mind and
consciousness is indicis that surrounds
you.
It's right.
It is transcendent.
I need to study a good depok impression.
Cause that one that's racist as fuck
your average Indian guy.
Well this is what he argues,
that when you die,
your consciousness,
your mind goes to where it was before
you were born.
Yeah.
But the problem is you don't fucking
know that.
Well,
no one and no one knows that.
So you can't say that.
That's what it does.
My argument is what?
Where were you before you were born?
I mean,
most people go,
well,
what do you mean?
That's a non question.
I wasn't anywhere before I was born.
Right.
And when you die that you won't be
anywhere now.
So,
but maybe by Buddhists think that,
um,
you know,
that you just returned to the
consciousness in the sky,
the forest,
this,
wherever it is.
I think our number one problem is that
we try to have a place where you go,
we try to have an explanation.
Yeah.
We feel like it's a place,
but depok tells me this is completely
wrong way to say it.
You're,
you're not going any place.
There's no place.
Hmm.
Well,
here's the problem.
Even with that,
I think there's an issue with saying
that you know anything about what
happens after death,
right?
You could have a ton of theories.
You can have
like possibilities that you ponder.
You could sit down and be as creative as
you want.
You could start and think about the,
the number of known stars in the
universe and then start to perceive how
immense the universe is and what,
what is going on in consciousness
itself.
And when it,
when it ends,
does that energy go somewhere and become
some thing that we haven't considered?
You could do that all day long.
Right?
And it's fun.
But the problem is when anyone says they
know when you go back to become a baby
again and your start the world from how
the fuck do you know you don't?
The answer is don't.
It's interesting to think that you might
be a baby again.
live you like I've heard the,
I forget what religion promotes this
possibility,
but that you live your entire life over
and over and over again until you get it
right.
And that's where the term old soul comes
from.
Like you're running like you're
obviously a very wise man,
Michael Shermer.
So you probably were an idiot a few
hundred thousand generations ago,
but you've gotten to this point where
you've,
you've figured out how to live your life
very harmoniously and in doing that you,
you exhibit all the traits of an old
soul.
This is instead of,
you know,
there's certain people up there,
we all have seen them on the Internet
that do ridiculous things and it's just
like,
why are they so stupid?
Why are they doing?
Well maybe they've only is their third
or fourth go around.
Yeah.
Maybe that's the,
that is entirely possible.
We don't know.
You don't know why you were born.
You don't know what happens when you
die.
The problem is in saying that you have
an explanation,
right?
Whether it's a materialist,
very cold,
scientific analysis of the possibilities
in terms of like what we know today and
deny any possibilities of anything being
anything other than death being the end
like that.
We don't know that either.
Well,
okay.
Right.
That's correct.
But so from the scientific,
no hypothesis that is your theory is not
true until proven otherwise we would be,
nothing happens when you're dead,
you're just gone.
Could be,
and t unless there's some other
alternative we can test.
Right.
So my,
one of my favorite thought experiments
comes from Carl Sagan,
demon haunted world.
Awesome book,
Awesome Book.
The chapter is called,
there's a dragon.
In my garage.
So,
uh,
I tell you,
Joe,
I have a dragon in my garage.
You do?
So cool.
Can I see it?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Here.
Curious.
I opened the garage door.
You look in and there's some paint cans.
A ladder.
A bike,
no dragon.
Oh,
well it's an invisible dragon.
Okay,
so you say a,
well,
let's put some powder down on the
ground.
And when he walks around,
we'll see his footprints.
Well,
you see this dragon hovers about three
feet above the ground at all times.
And you say,
well,
I got some infrared cameras here.
We could detect the heat.
Now this is a cold blooded drag and it
gives us no temperature at all.
You know,
oh,
I have this heat detector and when it
spits out the fire,
then we'll see that the fire comes out
of it.
And that'll prove that,
well,
no,
it's coal fire.
Now this is not heat generating.
Five is a very special kind of fire.
Okay,
so seconds point is what's the
difference between,
and you know,
invisible hovering cold in detectable,
immeasurable dragon and no dragon at
all.
So if there's not,
if there's not some way for us to get at
it,
then we can't assume it exists.
Exactly.
I would.
I apply that to God.
You know,
cause people do all God is outside of
space and time.
Okay.
How do you know if he's outside of space
and time and no way to measure it?
Well,
he reaches into the art world to stir
the particles,
cure the cancer,
whatever.
Okay.
Can we measure that and does it look
different from what happens naturally
now?
There's why w w why is it that would
always,
God always cures is things that might
have gotten better anyway.
You know,
tumors do go into remission and,
but most of them don't.
Most people,
they get cancer,
they die.
So why didn't God heal them?
He only seems to heal the ones that
naturally go into remission.
How come he doesn't grow amputated limbs
for Christian soldiers coming back from
a rack?
How come,
you know,
these are Christian families praying for
their Christian loved ones who lost a
limb.
You know he's busy curing cancer over
here,
but why can't he handled the ones that
never ever naturally grow back?
What's the difference between a
invisible dragon?
No Dragon.
Oh,
that's so always you know when yet.
But this is my theory of the afterlife
would,
that's nice.
How do you know
you do not?
You do not know.
And when it comes to religion,
the idea of some sort of a powerful
being that's in charge of the whole
picture and it's got a grand plan for it
all is a,
it's kind of comforting to some people
and it's,
and it's an interesting possibility.
And again,
it's something to consider.
It's something to think about.
It's an idea that's been around for a
long time.
Why has it been around for so long?
I don't know.
Well,
let's go over some of the other things
that had been around for a long time.
Let's look at what else is in that book.
Is there any other shit in that book
that you might think is ridiculous?
Oh,
isn't there a story in that book about
two children that taught demand because
he's bald.
So they sick bears on the kids.
Do you remember that story in the Bible?
Was it with his name?
But Lisa has what it was is the guy's
name who is taunted by these children
because of his baldness.
So God's summons to bears to come out of
the woods and mall these children and
kill them because they taunted his be
fade with the Old Testament.
I mean,
but if you're talking to someone who's a
religious person who believes in the
Bible and you throw that around,
one of the first things that goes well,
that's the Old Testament,
right?
Well,
okay,
so the Old Testament is not valid.
Right?
The New Testament,
the one that was written by constant
teen and a group of bishops,
when they got down,
they thought they wrote it out for what?
500 years after Jesus died.
That one's legit.
I see that.
Yeah.
We got some more ridiculous when
everyone,
cause constantine wasn't even,
he wasn't even Christian.
Wow.
Well
yeah.
Well,
Tom in the gospels appear to be 30
to 60,
the first one,
30 to 60 years after Jesus died,
book of Mark,
the others were copied from mark.
Obviously John is really weird and uh,
you know,
no one knew him.
These weren't,
you know,
the Gospel authors didn't know they
weren't his disciples,
they didn't know him.
So this is second hand,
third hand,
whatever.
And there was a committee that decided
what that's right.
Scott Bass for example,
was voted out.
Why?
Well,
yeah,
who knows?
It's a twitter poll.
Take a twitter poll.
Yeah.
The got all together evil twitter poll.
Yes.
And any case,
where did Jesus become a conservative?
You know,
I mean in the,
in the gospels he talks about,
uh,
you know,
giving up your belongings,
taken care of the poor,
you know,
uh,
the chances of a rich man going to
heaven or it's like going through the
eye of a needle.
You can't do it made wine for people
carpenter.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
So,
um,
his conservative values would be suspect
if you actually read what he said.
Yeah.
I mean all the depictions of them,
it looks like a fucking hippie.
It was like a dirty white hippie
somehow.
Another white guy,
I grew up in the Middle East and you
know the year zero I have a feeling they
probably looked like they look now,
don't you think?
I mean why is that guy looks so like he
looks like a lost kid who lives in
Idaho.
He's rebelling from his parents and well
I think that's what made the life of
Brian such a great film money pipeline.
It's like they really nailed it and they
nailed it a long time ago.
Right back when you really couldn't do
of this before blazing saddles.
It was super controversial movie at the
time and groundbreaking in terms of like
people,
we look at comedy from like the 60s or
the 70s and we look at it in terms of
what we know to be shocking and crazy
today and it's our bar's so different,
right?
It's hard when you go back and watch
those things to really take in the
context of,
I was talking to Guy Tory about this
funny comedian friend of mine about this
last night.
We were talking about um,
how good lenny bruce was and how we
really can understand it because comedy
is sort of,
it continues to progress and it sort of
reflects the attitudes of the times and
we're so much more open minded and so
much further down the line than we were
in 1960 whatever when lenny was getting
arrested for using bad words.
Right?
So it's hard for us to preciate it's
hard for us to really understand like if
we were kids back then and we went to
see Lenny Bruce and we were living in
this like really restrictive
environment,
that was the 1950s in 1960s then we'd be
blown away by it.
Like what is he saying?
This is right.
But today you listen to it and it's
almost pedestrian or have some of the
stuff that he has to say because it's
already been said because he broke down
the door.
Then it was like,
yeah,
that holds been there forever.
And they could even make blazing saddles
today because,
you know,
they use the n word constantly.
You're out there.
It's good point.
Could you make that movie,
uh,
one of the characters has that line
about a,
okay,
well let him the niggers in the big,
but not the Irish.
That's right.
Whoa.
You wouldn't say that today.
Even in us had tire.
We'll think about a character like
archie bunker.
Oh,
right,
right.
All in the family.
You couldn't do that show today the way
it is you,
it would be hateful and horrible and
they blago sphere would erupt the
honeymooners.
Jackie gleason used to threaten to beat
his wife,
all the to the moon.
He was gonna hit her so hard,
he's going to put her on the moon.
Right.
Hilarious.
Oh boy.
People used to smack people all the time
in movies.
Back then,
men were always beating women up.
Right.
It was like a natural part of behavior
to the point where we didn't even mind
it from heroes.
Heroes with smack a woman in the mouth
and she'd be like,
Ooh.
And then they would invariably wind up
fucking them.
Like right afterwards they'd smack them
and then they start making out.
Seinfeld is a little riff on Paul
Mccartney's.
Uh,
you got to run for your life.
You better run for your life if you can
a little girl,
cause I'll get you in the end.
And then the other one was,
she was just 17,
if you know what I mean.
Like,
no Paul,
what do you mean?
What are we talking about here?
But that's early sixties.
It was normal.
Like how about kiss?
They had that song,
Christine 16,
Gene Simmons a sang that song.
All right,
that was a big hit.
Christine's 16.
I've got to hover.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Well or you got to have you.
Yeah,
I think that's a good song.
But it's fucked up when you go back and
listen to it,
you know,
you realize like,
wow,
like you're singing about a little baby,
right.
You know,
like,
and you realize when you become,
you know,
I'm 49 now.
When you look at like a 16 year old,
you're like,
Jesus Christ like kid.
We'll give her a couple of years even
eighteens ridiculous.
Right,
right.
So what is legal and what is not legal
is very strange,
but those songs,
man.
So you know,
in terms of moral progress that that
kind of change happens to slow enough.
You don't really notice it,
but looking back a few decades,
it's like,
wow,
look what they used to say in movies or
novels.
What does this compilation immense mcing
women,
oh,
this is airplay airplay yet,
but they're there.
That's what they're spoofing.
Say,
oh,
this is hilarious.
Boom,
there we go.
To movies were crazy.
They would just mack,
he punched her and dropped her.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like backhand in Sean Connery.
Marilyn Sean connery was interviewed by
Barbara Walters and he was advocating
smacking women.
Yup.
From charms.
Just keep pushing it and they won't let
it go and you have to give them a smart
and she was like,
are you saying that you stretched your
truck trucker where I'm trying like the
bogart line.
I never met a team that didn't was it
didn't like a smack in the mouth or a
Clo Colt 45 or whatever.
It's a slug from a goal 40
a woman now,
and then as I remember you said you
don't do it with a clenched fist.
It's better to do it with an open hand.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
I'm not going to love that.
I haven't changed my opinion.
No.
You think it's good to slap a woman?
No,
I don't think it's good,
but I don't think it's bad that I don't
think it's bad.
I think that it depends entirely on the
circumstances and if it marriage it and
what would narrate it.
Well,
if you have tried everything else and
they kind of put it alone,
you don't want to have the last word,
then you give them the laughing last
word,
but they're not happy with the last one.
They want to share it again and and get
into a really provocative situation.
Then one and a half million.
Absolutely right.
What year was that?
That looks like maybe eighties I want to
say it was later than that and I don't
want to say it was the 90s that's
pretty.
That's pretty well.
You know he's old,
but that's a generation.
Sometimes they won't bother to go,
well it's a Donald Donald Sterling,
you know,
he's just an old 1987.
Interesting.
Well it's,
it's interesting cause is looking away
as she says it and then looks at him
when she hits him with a question,
like it's a gotcha moment.
Right.
And I haven't transmart preneurial not
at all.
He like,
he like hits her with that like,
whoa.
So that was like,
there was a lot of,
that was a game too.
That was also,
she provoked him in this way where,
you know,
he's a chauvinist and some of her that
did that with Mike Tyson,
with the,
with his wife,
uh,
pet beauty pageant woman,
I forget her name.
Yeah.
That he used to batter.
How was the end of their marriage right
there on the show?
Well,
it,
it certainly sent him,
well,
it sent him on a spiraling,
I think they stayed married for quite a
while after the show,
but she was on the show.
Talk about a whole horrific it is to
live with him and how he's crazy and,
but of course he is.
He's Mike fucking Tyson,
right?
He's one of the most terrifying combat
sport athletes the world's ever known.
His success is,
it's focused entirely on him being
violent as humanly possible beyond the
limitations of other people who are
professional purveyors of violence.
Like he's the best at it,
right?
Brand of violence is so much more
ferocious than any other fucking person
who's ever done it before.
He makes all these other professional
heavyweight boxers look like pussies.
They see him,
they practically faint,
throws punches that miss and they fall
down.
He said,
of course,
he's not like,
what are we doing here?
Why you have this guy on television?
What kind of a person that you like?
What is what this therapy
session like?
What,
what is she doing?
Like the wife,
You,
are you doing this publicly because you
believe this is the only way to reach
him?
Is that the only thing?
There was a minor controversy bit.
This is before the Internet,
so it didn't go viral.
But,
um,
the La Times had a story about the rams
defensive line that was called the
fearsome foursome in the 19,
late sixties,
early seventies.
And,
uh,
you know,
Rosie greer was one of them and he was
just terrifying,
I guess.
And he was talking about how he would
head slap the other Lineman,
like,
you know,
the snap and he banned like this,
right?
Then they had an open hole there for the
ears.
So the air pressure would like break the
guy's eardrum if he did it right and
this would throw him off a little bit,
then he could sack the quarterback or
whatever.
This was his thing.
And then he mentioned like in the
interview,
and I,
you know,
I had slapped my,
my girlfriend or my wife or whatever.
It was like,
what,
wait,
what you do this to you?
It was like,
holy moly.
And it didn't make a big thing,
but it was there in the title.
I remember reading it thinking,
God Dang,
she's,
you know,
if you're,
if you're six,
eight and your weight 300 pounds and you
have a helmet,
that's one thing.
But if you know a little Bam,
well,
and this was also probably tolerated so
much back then that those women didn't
have any recourse.
They couldn't go to a tmz or something
like that.
They couldn't take video and put it on
their phone and then put it on the
Internet and have it go viral.
They were scared.
I mean,
if you've got some six eight 400 pound
gigantic dude wants to hit you,
and he also had sex with you,
like,
fuck,
how do you get out of that?
It's hard enough to get out of a regular
relationship,
right?
Like the poor lady who had to get on
stage with Anthony Robbins and call her
boyfriend.
You know?
I mean that's rough.
But imagine if her boyfriend is a
fucking giant football player who likes
hitting her.
Right?
And it was,
if it was in the movies like that and
you have sean connery talking about it
on tv,
it becomes accepted.
Like then we get into this whole
determinism thing like is that guy
beating his wife,
beating his wife because of the culture
that he lives in?
And is that,
is it,
I mean is how much is that affecting his
conscious decisions and does he have the
freewill to escape that influence?
The way that moral progress of works in
this regard over long periods of time is
that it just never enters your mind to
do it if you never see it or hear about
it.
And that reduces the number of people
that do it.
So you know in Sean Connery's
generation,
you just showed all those movie clips.
That's probably all he saw was yet
that's what you do.
And it does.
This would never enter my mind to do
this.
I mean it doesn't even,
no matter how bad,
but temporarily I'm not going to
reach out and introduce you to a few
checks.
The ones that want the last word.
Yeah,
it's called break up with them.
Sean,
get out of the house,
go drive.
You've got a porsche.
I'm going to the hill.
Fuck off.
Just go drive.
You can get a hotel room somewhere dude,
you're super rich.
You know you have to stay with that
crazy lady.
Well that's the,
that's one of the sort of self
controlled techniques,
but count to 10,
leave the room.
We are in many ways,
um,
sort of a,
a product of our environment.
The,
in the way that we imitate our
atmosphere so
much mean we have patterns of,
of talking,
we,
there's expressions that are like
similar or familiar to certain areas.
We have accents that distinguished that.
We belong in this clan of people that
live in Boston for instance,
where I grew up,
there's a Boston accent,
it's so clear and if you talk to people
that live there,
they're letting you know that they're
local.
Like they're,
they're,
they're like the,
and everybody sort of assimilates with a
certain way of thinking and a way of
being.
And it's super common to,
for people to adopt a predetermined
pattern of behavior rather than having
to think things all the way through for
themselves.
So if that predetermined pattern
behavior means you girlfriend mouth's
off,
you fucking smack her in the head.
They start doing it like it's right.
Whereas today it's thought of as a
horrific thing to do.
You're,
you're a domestic violence person.
You,
you,
you've,
you've hit someone,
you've committed assault,
you know,
all those horrible words and thoughts
that we have attached to these things
that were almost nonexistent back then,
right.
Just a hundred years ago.
Right.
Totally normal.
So this process probably started in the
late Middle Ages.
There's a book called the civilizing
process by Norbert Elliot,
say sociologists that Steve Pinker kind
of made prominent in his book,
the better angels of our nature.
Talking about how,
just like books of manners and table
manners and how you interact with other
people.
Nonviolently you know,
don't have a knife,
don't care your knife with you or you
know,
he had a knife to somebody who's
supposed to hand it with the handle,
you know,
forward and,
and you know,
don't do certain things that,
you know,
don't urinate in the hallways,
don't defecate in the,
you know,
this just basically these people were
gross and here's how not to be gross.
Don't act like pig.
Don't act like right.
And in a way it's,
it's training your brain to gain self
control over your impulses.
Like,
I'd really just like to take a shit
right over there.
Well,
don't do it.
I mean it's not cool.
We don't do that.
Okay,
I won't.
And then then an even never enters your
mind to do anything like that.
And so the argument is that we've been
on this 500 year long civilizing process
of just training people to control their
impulses.
Impulse control is that prefrontal
cortex keeping a break on the,
you know,
the sort of lower impulses that bubble
up.
I'd really like to do that,
not going to do it.
And then pretty soon you don't even
think about doing it.
Now obviously there's still a handful of
the psychopaths or whatever,
they don't care,
but fewer and fewer of us and just from
the interview,
so sean connery's generation versus our
generation versus our kids,
uh,
you know,
this is just disappearing from our
vocabulary,
from our repertoire of behaviors that we
will employ with other people.
You just don't even think about doing
that.
That's the,
that's how moral progress happens from
the bottom up.
It completely makes sense and it
completely makes sense when you look at
the history of humanity,
how much safer it is today relatively
than at any other time in terms of like
how much violence you're going to
encounter and you daily life when we see
violence to incredibly shocking.
Whereas if we lived 5,000
years ago,
it'd be incredibly rare to get through
life without seeing dead buys.
Like you,
you became much more custom to the
temporary nature of being and the threat
of violence being a real part of
everyday life.
Right?
Or is this not anymore?
So I think one of the things that's
happening as we create new technology
that sort of alleviates the physical
stress of life or the worry of dying or
we extend life to the point and fix,
uh,
illnesses to the point where life
becomes a little bit more,
a little bit more durable,
a little and people will relax more and
more about the fee,
like the physical requirements our
bodies had a few thousand years ago,
we were hunters and gatherers.
We're constantly worried about
predators.
That physical,
physical requirements and the dangers
that you had to be able to experience
and mitigate and get through every day.
We're so much more,
so much more dangerous than what we
experience on a daily basis,
other than like car accidents and things
along those lines.
Right?
But we still have all those fight or
flight responses.
We still have those reward systems that
need to be fed because we're essentially
in the same,
you know,
give or take a few genetic mutations,
the same bodies that people had 10,000
years ago,
right?
Yup.
It's like that little line.
The three F's,
fight,
flight or reproduction or threes.
That's the other one or phrase.
Yeah.
Big One is when people don't consider is
why do people,
why do certain people not run,
not fight,
but panic lock up.
Right?
What's going on there?
Because that's a real response.
That is super common.
That doesn't get addressed in that fight
flight response.
Right?
There's also people that can work,
fucking freeze.
But all of those
things,
uh,
in a more dangerous world actually do
age you faster that some of the research
I was reading these books about aging,
uh,
is this,
the more stress you have itch it,
it does.
Those stress hormones leads to more
inflammation.
There's more and more stuff about
inflammation and disease,
inflammation and Alzheimer's Information
and the telomeres shortens your life.
And there was this big study on possums
in Florida,
the ones that are out in the wild
getting run over and attacked and preyed
upon versus ones that were put on this
island where there was no predators,
all the food that they want.
And you know,
the ones,
the ones that lived on the island live
significantly longer but like,
like 50% longer and not just accounted
for by the ones that got run over.
Not that just the aging,
the aging president,
just living in an open dangerous
environment takes its toll on your cell,
eular,
reproduction and how long you live,
uh,
irrespective of predation and accidents.
Um,
so this is back to the,
you know,
meditation take,
take it easy,
lower those stress hormones because they
do take a toll on your body.
Yeah,
unquestionably.
I mean it must the,
the,
the idea that you could
get through life red lining it all the
time and not have,
yeah.
It's just like people ask that don't
know much about football.
Why can't they play the whole game?
Like the final two minutes?
Jesus.
Well,
you can't do it.
Yeah.
I mean it's just football in and of
itself.
Like how long can you do that?
Like does anybody ever figured out how
many times you can get hit by a guy
who's 350 lbs running 30 miles an hour.
I mean,
those guys are giant and they're huge
super athletes and they collide with
each other.
I don't think a person like you or me
could even appreciate the amount of
impact that's involved in a lineman who
was just a giant mountain of a man using
all of his might and running into you.
I don't think I can understand it.
I think I like watch it on TV and I see,
boom,
what guy's feet are up in the air and
they'd go slam.
But I don't think,
I don't think I physically can feel it.
I don't think,
I don't think I get it right.
I just think it's no,
that story of the,
uh,
you know,
how could the concussion story,
uh,
that was first broke by espn and a duck
or a frontline in a two hour
documentary,
uh,
that guy that died,
the Pittsburgh steelers center,
Mike,
uh,
what was the guy,
I forget his name.
Jamie's a big sports fan.
Like he was featured in the movie that,
uh,
the Wilson Smith movie.
Yeah.
But,
but the,
the docs calculated that in the course
of his life,
say from high school football,
College football,
and 20 seasons of the NFL and all the
practices all week,
and then the game,
you know,
and he webster,
yeah.
Mike Webster,
you probably got hit.
It hit the equivalent of a minor
concussion,
you know,
thousands,
maybe tens of thousands of times.
And that,
you know,
that's the cumulative effects.
Um,
are you so crazy?
What is this?
What does this change?
And I felt like God,
okay.
So in 1927 they were 190 pounds and six
feet tall.
So a 190 pounds is six pounds less than
me.
And I'm,
I'm not a big person.
I'm five foot eight.
So they're a little taller at six foot
for the average lyman,
which is a giant person right now in
2000 and what is the last one?
Eight Jamie,
what does it say?
Scroll down.
I'll share this part at the bottom,
which just how hard is there hit star.
But 2006 you get to the average lyman is
six foot four 335 he's not the average.
He's the outlier though.
Cause he said hello.
He nodded.
He,
he's a,
he's a little bit big,
but still you can see are a little bit
smaller than him,
but still they're all over 300 pounds.
If I look at it,
I mean I remember Alan Page,
he was huge.
He was massive and it just one of the
great and he only two 45 you probably
wouldn't even make the,
the uh,
the,
the main team now.
Right.
And what year was that?
Scroll down please.
67 so in 67.
Yeah.
67.
That guy was like,
like if you see like how big George
Foreman was right when George Foreman
was the heavyweight champ.
He was gigantic.
But I don't,
I mean when he came back,
when he started comeback,
he was well over
300 pounds and he was really overweight.
But I don't think he was that big when
he was fighting.
I think he was in the two twenties to
thirties when he was a heavyweight
champion.
I'll beat him some of this stuff,
like the ones on the right there,
there's a lot of body fat that's,
no,
of course not.
Yeah.
I mean there's more mass like the sumo
wrestlers.
You want mass,
not just muscle.
Yeah.
You know,
they also,
those guys are just all about power.
They're all about power and weight
behind power.
And there are certain amount of time,
like if you have the same amount of
power but more weight behind it,
you can actually probably have more of
an impact when you're colliding with
people.
Right?
Like if you ever tried to wrestle with a
big person,
like even if they're not strong,
like the amount of mass that you have to
move when you're wrestling around with
them.
Like right.
You don't consider it until someone,
like,
until you're in a situation like I guess
if you had never played football before
and then you ran out there and you were
on the front line and you'd be like,
okay,
what does this going to be like?
No,
there's no way.
You know what,
that 330 pound dude feels like.
Well,
he's right.
Full blast into you,
but crazy fucking sport.
Yeah.
I'm reading this book now called
spitting in the soup,
um,
about the history of doping in sports.
That goes back to the late 19th century
and half of it is just for survival.
Uh,
you know,
you take these drugs just to get through
the next week and the next game,
the next contest.
Um,
and then,
and how it was this guy's argument is
that it was pretty accepted,
common and known.
Uh,
the guy that won the Tour de France five
times,
um,
uh,
used to say that you,
you can't expect us to do this on bread
and water.
I mean,
you know,
we raised 250 times a year and you know,
six,
eight hours a day of killing ourselves.
Sean Cockatiel,
the French great friends,
cyclists.
But this appears to be true in most
sports.
And that it wasn't until the,
that I think it was 1906 Olympics when
people started equating doping with sin.
Like this is a moral thing.
Like you're getting,
you're cheating as opposed to,
it's just a medical thing.
You know,
I,
I train,
I lift weights,
I do this,
I eat this diet,
I take these drugs.
It's all kind of part of the mix of
being an athlete.
And then there was a transition.
He argues socially or morally or
whatever.
And all these things are good,
but this,
this one thing over here is bad,
like say,
and cycling your Hematocrit is important
because you're delivering oxygen to your
muscles.
So,
uh,
if you know,
you and I probably have 45 to 50%
hermatocrit that's the number of red
blood cells in your blood.
So half are red blood cells delivering
oxygen to your muscles.
So,
uh,
now if you're like in the low thirties,
that's anemic.
And this drug epo,
uh,
invented by Amgen was created to save
patients that are anemic from cancer
treatment or whatever.
It's a great drug,
but so it wasn't long before the cyclist
got ahold of this in the late eighties,
early nineties.
Like,
well,
okay,
if 45%,
if I'm naturally a 45% and you're at
50%,
I'm losing a little edge.
So I'll just,
I'll train at high altitude,
I'll sleep in the oxygen tent or I'll
just take the injection.
And so 50% is good.
How about 55%?
Well,
that'd be even better.
How about 60% and the guy who won the 96
tour bjarney reese,
he was nicknamed was Mr 60% and he's
like mud flows.
And also then,
but then,
uh,
some cyclists started dying in the early
nineties and mid nineties.
There was maybe a dozen or two that died
mysteriously and it was never clear what
the cause was.
So everybody said it's the epo they
take,
you know,
the blood is too thick there.
It's having strokes or heart attacks
and,
and even I bought this idea.
Yeah,
I guess that's it.
I wrote this article for Scientific
American about doping in sports.
So this is why it's wrong because people
are dying.
But this guy's argument is,
is it was never proven that these people
died.
And furthermore,
he takes on steroids.
You know,
this is the whole thing that started
with lyall Elsedo,
the Oakland Raiders linebacker who said,
you know,
I got brain cancer is after he was done
playing,
but he said it was,
it was dude,
all the steroids I was taking.
Then the meme started,
oh,
steroids causes cancer,
steroids feeds,
cancer,
causes tumors to grow.
This guy is saying that's never been
proven.
And so I'm,
I'd like to look into this more before
and review this book.
You know,
is this really true?
How do we know that steroids are
dangerous?
I mean,
isn't it the dosage?
You know,
it's mckelly Ferrari said Lance's doping
doctor,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's the orange juice.
If you drink too much orange juice is
dangerous.
It's the dose,
you know,
so some steroids,
I'm epo some growth hormone,
you know,
I mean,
some of this should be maintenance.
Like what triggered this was looking at
those huge guys.
I mean,
you get pounded,
you got to play again next week.
How do you do that?
Well,
I gotta I gotta take that,
get the massage,
take the Jacuzzi,
you know,
and take some drugs.
That was the premise of bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Oh,
right.
It was a big thing.
Was that,
where are all the bodies?
Like where,
where is this,
this steroid epidemic that people are
talking about?
What you've looking at even at,
in bodybuilders.
I mean,
some of them do die from it,
but the sheer amount of drugs those guys
are taking to achieve those behemoth
sizes.
Yeah,
I give you look at some pro body have
just outlandishly huge.
A lot of those guys,
it's a battle of who can take the most
drugs,
who could power lift the most?
We can lift the most.
We could train the hardest,
but also who can tolerate the most
ridiculous levels of these drugs.
And so some of those guys die.
Right?
But well there's the dosage is yes,
exactly.
Because the amount of people that are
doing them is off the charts.
If you think about professional
athletes,
you think about all the different
athletes that are doing performance
enhancing drugs.
If they were really dying from this
stuff,
it to body should be everywhere,
everywhere.
It should be just dropping like flies,
I
think.
I think they're just getting smarter
about it and they know it's called
microdosing.
In cycling with the EPA,
you just take a little bit,
just give it just a little bump just for
maintenance,
you know?
And I wrote that story for scientific
American.
I interview George,
um,
Frankie Andrea,
who was one of lance his teammates,
uh,
in the 99 and 2000 seasons that he won.
And he took epo and he didn't,
didn't really want to avoid it as long
as he could,
but he said he was just getting dropped
from the main Peloton and he couldn't
even do his job is just the lances
domestique to carry his water bottles
up.
You know,
you're,
you're up there in the front with Lance,
dropped back to the team car,
get some water bottles,
then you've got to ride all the way back
up to the front,
which is hard to do when these guys are
cruising along at 30 miles an hour.
Yeah.
So you've got to be fit.
So he said he was getting dropped just
doing that.
So it was like,
I can't,
I can't even be on the team,
can't do my job.
So he took it just to,
just to stay in the race,
just so I could be a bicyclist.
Just say to deliver water.
Yeah.
And a,
I think a lot of them do that.
You know,
it's like I don't want to do it,
but you know it got to do it cause stay
healthy and strong and keep going.
Well you'd have a unique insight into it
because you did a lot of cycling.
Yeah.
And you did it at a very high and
competitive level so you had an inside
view as to the requirements.
And I think it's one of the more,
more unique sports in that the
requirements are so incredibly grueling
and the amount of time that you're
working,
like you might not be working with as
much effort,
say as a sprinter whose running 100
meter like a Usain bolt tight character.
But the amount of time involved in
expenditure of energy is huge.
It's one of the more unique and weird
things about cycling is you're doing it
for an hour.
Like what is one day in the Tour de
France?
Notice how I said France,
France.
Oh there,
there was a,
you know,
usually four to six hours,
four to six hours of pumping your legs.
She,
it was six hours.
That's crazy.
When you think about it.
So even if it's easier than running a
sprint,
even if it's easier than running up to
the top of a hill,
the amount of time you're spending doing
it is another consideration.
And then mentally the drag on maintain
it was,
must be huge.
Must be crazy.
Well,
this is when I interviewed Greg Lamond.
Uh,
he said that his teammates came to him,
this was in the 91 or 92 season in his
last,
and when epo was,
was rampid in the Peloton,
everyone figured it out.
Greg didn't want to do that,
do it.
And his teammates are saying,
well we,
you know,
just the course of a three week tour,
just your medica just drops just from
fatigue.
He said everybody else,
it's not like they're getting an unfair
advantage by going above their normal,
they're just staying level.
Whereas the rest of us are dropping off.
And then the last few stages you're
wiped out.
Right.
So,
you know,
it's like we got to do this just to stay
with the rest of the field.
So the level playing field argument I
guess,
you know,
in terms of morals,
we sort of draw the line at the needle
when there's a needle involved I guess
or you know,
a patch or a pill,
it feels different than training at high
altitude or sleeping in the oxygen tent.
Um,
you know,
like the climbers to uh,
taking epl feels like it's more
artificial.
This guy's argument of this book
spitting in the soup is that it's just a
great Asian and we've just arbitrarily
drawn the line there and uh,
you know,
I think there's much of it in the NFL
has got it just be getting to the end of
the season and still being able to play
just because it's so hard.
Well I think that argument is very good
because there's certain supplements that
you can take through effective that
actually do work.
So how do we to stay and what was your
staff that,
um,
that the baseball players,
uh,
andrew now understand on,
but they will most likely it is that
most likely bullshit.
Most likely there was an excuse for them
doing actual steroids.
Right?
Cause I think that Mark McGuire,
yes,
I think that some forms of that stuff,
some forms of those,
what they call pro hormones can actually
trigger positive test results in maybe
primitive like back then when they were
testing people,
which is like nothing compared to what
they're doing now,
which is why really interestingly two
Russian Olympic wrestlers have been
stripped of their gold metals because
uh,
of the past,
I think from 2008 they didn't even get
the 2012 results in because they took
their samples that they had back then.
And now with newer,
more sophisticated levels of testing,
they've been able to show that these
guys were doing some shit.
But the UFC is a,
an interesting proving ground for it
because,
uh,
Jeff Novitsky who was the head of Usada
and the drug program that got Lance
Armstrong and a bunch of other people
Novitsky now works for the UFC and he
is,
oh yes.
Oh yes.
And he has for quite a while now and he
has almost completely cleaned up the
amount of people that are doing things
that people still get caught every now
and then.
But the amount of people that who were
their physiques have changed where their
performance has changed.
Where there results inside the octagon
of like drastically dropped off is
pretty obvious.
Insignificant to the point where MMA
fans and you know the pundits and
analysts are looking at this and they're
going,
wow,
this is fascinating.
Like you're,
you're seeing people change.
Like there's even a term that we use an
MMA like pre Usada like we use pre Usada
and post Usada like they got him off the
drugs are the fight still is good,
exciting to watch.
Well,
the best guys for sure.
Yeah,
the best guys are still the best guys.
But there's some guys that were the best
guys that were on legal stuff like they
used to have allow testosterone
replacement therapy.
It used to be legal,
so all you had to do was take steroids,
go to your doctor,
get off the steroids,
testosterone crashes,
you go to the doctors,
Hey dog,
man,
I got,
I think I got low test.
You know what son?
You have a condition,
it's called low testosterone and they
would prescribe it for you.
The same way,
like when you were talking about
alcohols and being a disease,
they would just decided that
testosterone loss as a disease and this
man needs his medicine.
And so they would give these guys
testosterone in like 35 36 year old guys
would be just jacked,
jacked and fighting.
Not just jacked and going to the beach,
but like involved in a sport where your
whole purpose is to do physical harm to
your opponent,
right?
So this drug allows you to do are more
physical harm,
which is very different than cycling.
Like if a guy gets really good at
cycling and he has to use drugs to get
really good at cycling and he's cheating
to win,
that's one thing.
But if he's doing these drugs and it's
allowing him to put other people in the
hospital,
things get very weird.
Well,
in terms of the moral argument,
um,
if you're saying that the fights are,
are just as fun to watch,
they're exciting,
competitive without the drugs and fewer
people are harmed from taking the drugs,
then maybe that's a good thing.
That would be argument for Usada.
The argument can even be said that the
fights are more exciting because people
are more vulnerable.
They get knocked out easier,
they get tired easier and sometimes it
makes fights crazier.
Okay,
let's cut.
Guys have tested positive for epo after
even championship level fights.
There was this guy I'll bag routine off
who's a top flyweight fighter and
interesting enough he fought a guy who
doesn't dope,
who's the best pound for pound fighter
in the world is Guy Demetrius mighty
mouse Johnson and the mighty mouse beat
him.
One of the ways he beat him is with
volume and pace.
Like this guy couldn't keep up his pace
because it's right.
Efficiency of technique is also like
really critical in mma because the guy
who doesn't have efficiency and puts too
much kinetic energy and muscle behind
techniques,
they tend to fade quicker.
It can have positive results if you
catch someone with a shot.
But if you don't over the long period of
time,
you're draining your gas tank to get a
single and a single ballot in a single
bound.
So this efficiency overcame the drugs.
The other guy was on like his,
his physical efficiency in this
technique.
So the problem is starting and stopping
the arms race,
right?
Bodybuilding,
arms,
race,
the moment somebody could get away with
it,
then everybody thinks that it's being
done,
then they have to do it.
Then you have this behavioral game
theory thing of the,
of an arms race.
So Novitsky his point I guess is we were
going to nip it in the bud.
No one's gonna do it and we're going to
make the consequences,
you know,
super harsh suspensions.
What are the,
what is it like a two year suspension if
you get caught and a bunch of people
have gotten that two years.
And also you have to let you saw to know
where you are every minute of every day
I'm testing,
I'm going fishing,
I'm going to be on Lake Mead.
You know,
if you want to find me,
that's where I am.
And then you might get a text while
you're on Lake Mead,
come to the dock.
You got to go to the doc and there's a
guy standing there and he's going to
take your blood.
Right.
I had child son and on the podcast and
he was talking about how invasive it was
and how crazy it is.
They just show up wherever you are.
And he was doing,
they were,
they were doing it in like a closet with
like a mop and everything.
He's like,
this is not a sanitary,
you taking my blood in this weird
environment like this is,
this is kind of fucked up there.
They're just trying to catch people.
Well,
that'll be interesting to see what
happens with these leaks that are coming
out.
Uh,
yesterday that the Russians hacked the
Usada database.
They had a,
the William Sisters and the gymnast
Biles,
Simone Biles,
and
you know,
they're threatening to release more,
uh,
in the,
in the coming days.
And they were on all kinds of,
like,
they didn't say what they were on,
but that they had medical exemption.
Well,
one of them was oxycodone.
One of the William Sisters was on,
she was on oxygen.
So miles is taking that I think Rydell
and medication for Adhd.
And she came out I think today and made
a statement about it.
Oh really?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well that's a readily,
isn't really real in a form of
[inaudible] is in a form of like an
amphetamine or should it be to
stimulant?
Why would think that a stimulant would
be a performance enhancing drug?
Why would they let you do?
Right,
right.
Well,
pretty impressive.
Launched in the air though.
And that split,
look at that picture.
That's crazy.
What's it say?
I have adhd and if taking medicine for
it,
since I was a kid,
please know,
I believe in Kink,
clean sport.
I've always followed the rules and we'll
continue to do so.
As far as play fair play is critical to
sport and is very important to me.
What does that mean?
Well,
what does that mean?
Like how does Adhd,
how has that affected by Ritalin?
Like what is speed due to soil is Adh
did it,
it's one of these counterintuitive
things that,
I can't remember what the chemistry of
it is,
but the stimulant actually counters the
hyper activity and it slows you down.
It's a weird thing.
I can't remember why it is hyper
activity.
Uh,
controversial.
well Ange,
Adhd as well.
This is one of those sort of loose big
categories that more and more people
have gotten tossed into.
It used to be the little boy in fourth
grade was just,
you know,
he was just,
I had a lot of energy and he was always
running around.
Now he's got a disease,
he's got adhd while we got to medicate
him.
Why not just let them go out and have a
little longer plate playtime,
you know,
this is one of the counter arguments to
the disease model.
I mean,
again,
it's back to that.
It's a behavior.
Uh,
now it's a disease.
So we got to treat it with a drug.
Uh,
you know,
so you have this overmedication effect.
Now I can't say I was a parent of an
Adhd kid.
I wouldn't be glad to have some meds,
but I think the consensus is as far to
mow much medication of children,
uh,
who really it the be hate.
You know,
it's a spectrum,
you know,
if you're just completely out of control
of it here,
but most that are taking the drugs are
probably in the bell curve somewhere.
Not that bad.
I think that's really important that you
point that out,
that there is this great big spectrum.
Like a lot of things we've been talking
about.
There's,
there's people that are almost
unmanageable and these people that
might,
a kid that might just be a little bit
rowdy,
you know,
mean she just jumps up and down on the
couch and you tell her not to and you're
like,
I'm getting this fucking kid on some
pills.
And in a lot of it is,
you know,
teachers want control of the classroom.
It's this old,
it goes back to the 19th century.
You don't get to put them all in rows
because we're training them to work in
industry or be in the military.
It's really all it was and that's all it
still is and we're,
we're stuck with the echoes of that.
They're to the point where if you want
do something like there's a lot of
things that you can do for a living that
don't involve the traditional model of
what they're trying to teach you in
school.
And when you think about
those things is options.
They think they,
they,
they seem preposterous and they seem
like a pipe dream.
Like this idea that you're going to be a
famous author.
Yeah,
sure you are.
Well,
they like your,
that you're going to be in a band.
Oh yeah.
You too.
Congratulations when someone's in a
fucking band.
Right?
If someone in a band,
like we get all this music,
all right,
someone's playing this music.
Right?
How come I can't do it?
You can't do it.
No,
I have to work.
I have to get up and work.
Like we train these people to think that
this is the path that everyone has to
take and the occasional person ejects
from that path and goes and makes their
own knives or you know,
and start some sort of a weird business.
But why can't anybody who wants to do
that do that?
Well they can.
The problem is the most impressionable
part of your life.
They're teaching a really important
things like math and science and English
and grammar and we all need those
things,
but they're also teaching you patterns
and they're teaching you about the
potential for your future and this
potential for your future becomes like a
reality that you can't escape because
everybody else has done it.
Your friends are all doing it.
What will call with college are you
applying to?
Like what are you,
what are you gonna major when you're
like,
when are you going to take the bar?
Like what do you want to be a singer?
Stigmatize people who don't go to
college.
So everyone feels like,
well,
I got to go to college and the fact is
not everyone should go to college.
There's really no need for it.
It's a waste of time and money.
Uh,
they're not going to get any valuable
skills that they can actually use.
And they don't even want to be there.
But they feel like,
like my parents want me to go and my
friends are all going and society.
He says,
I gotta have a decree,
so I got to go.
You know.
And so now he had this perforation
operation of colleges and universities
that,
and you know,
the skyrocketing costs and so on.
What was wrong with trade schools,
you know,
now trade schools are kind of looked
down upon.
There's nothing wrong with trade
schools.
Trade schools are great,
but you know,
sort of stigmatized it.
And I think it's artificially putting
people in places where they feel
inadequate because actually somewhere
else they'd be,
they'd be making a lot of money at a
particular trade that they're really
good at and they'd be happy.
And,
but we've altered that since the second
world war that's happened.
The structure of school.
Uh,
I think it benefits kids and it gives
them discipline and like,
well,
you gotta get up at seven o'clock in the
morning,
you got to get there and you got to
figure out how to get your body to get
up.
You got to figure out how to fire your
mind up.
But your first class at 8:00
AM I think all that's probably good
because it's tests,
it's like you're,
you're overcoming.
And then in,
in overcoming and getting through those
tests at school or getting through
whatever weird social stuff you got
going on in your classroom,
you develop a sort of some data and get
some experience about the world.
Yeah,
there's something to that,
but I just think this model that they
want people to follow,
when I see most people following this
model,
I'm like,
is this,
this,
just because people haven't been
creative,
they haven't been imaginative and
thinking about what they would like to
do better than what they're doing now,
or is it just this,
this pattern is so easy to slip into and
we don't even realize it until you're in
it.
And then he can't get out of it.
Right.
I am by,
uh,
by like you,
udacity and the MOOC courses,
the teaching company courses,
all the audible books.
And you know,
there's so many ways to get a free
education online.
Most of this stuff is free or super
cheap.
Uh,
the knowledge is accessible.
It's there for everybody.
You know,
it's,
it's sort of the how you're going to dis
in a discipline way,
get the information,
the thing that,
that words the keyword,
right?
Discipline.
Yeah.
Because the difference between what
you're going to do on your own versus
what you're going to do in college are
very,
very different,
right?
Yeah.
But then the question becomes,
is it healthy to take some 19 year old
kid in the,
you know,
the most promising and fun and exciting
moment of her life,
right?
You're a teenager,
you're leaving your parents' house and
burden them with some insane work load
of shit that they have to do to the
point where they're always stressed out.
They're constantly dealing with tasks
are always turning,
turning,
turning in papers.
They're always,
they always have to do research.
they're constantly working.
Like if you look at the workload of a,
a kid in college,
right?
Like,
yes,
it teaches them discipline.
Yes.
It teaches them that it's hard out there
and you've got to really figure out how
to push yourself.
It does all those things,
but it also robs them of a lot of fun
times,
right.
In these years of their life.
And I'm not exactly sure if everything
that they're learning and they're
spending all this time on is even ever
going to be beneficial.
Right.
In fact,
the argument would be that most of it is
fucking nonsense and you're never going
to use it.
Right.
And meanwhile,
you're 19 you know,
and you should be having fun and
enjoying the vitality.
Marion,
I was at Pepperdine University in
Malibu.
I was the first member of the first four
year graduating class,
1976 classes 76 and I was at the jock
dorm with a bunch of baseball players
and tennis players and just just rowdy
guys and they're all,
I can't wait to get out of college.
I didn't want to get out there on my
own.
It's like,
when are we ever going to live in Malibu
again?
You know,
here we are playing ping pong and he'd
go and just having,
you know,
there's the ocean Pacific Ocean is right
there and the gym and you know,
it's like,
unless you're oprah or something,
you're not going to be living like this
again.
So,
so true.
That place isn't like the perfect spot.
He mentioned that land now.
Oh my God,
Mrs ever bought that and gave it to
George Pepperdine,
the company that ran it at school and
like 69 or something.
That chunk of land it at a Malibu Canyon
road and pch.
That'd probably be billions of dollars
now.
Probably will be right.
If you stop and think about our mission
would let them build anything.
That's right.
Get 'em laker tickets.
Did you see this uh,
Itt Tech?
You'd mentioned trade schools that made
me think of it.
This shit that happened like the last
two weeks,
they got completely shut down by the
Department of Education.
Whoa.
Says former ITT tech students declared
debt strike.
I am stuck up to my neck in debt for the
rest of my life and quote.
Yeah.
The problem with the,
that my argument for tech schools are
good is a lot of them get,
you know,
they,
they turn into these diploma mills,
they basically are for profit,
right.
Okay.
To have a profit company.
But you know,
for something like this and you end up
churning out students that can't get
jobs,
but they have this huge debt.
And they were,
the reason this is the story is because
the federal government was financing
some of their tuition.
Uh,
but it turns out,
you know,
it was not quite a pyramid scheme,
but something along those lines.
And so the government just said,
well,
we're not going to do this anymore.
This is the tax dollars.
And so now the students don't get the
financing anymore and the school is
still charging 50,000
a year or something.
It's like,
that's the end of the game.
Wow.
So a lot of these private tech school or
just private schools in general depend
on federal government money through the
students.
So they're not really for profit in the
sense of we're competing in the
marketplace like apple versus ibm and
it's,
you know,
the best product will win.
It's not like that they're getting
subsidized,
heavily subsidized,
but yet the price is so elevated that
people can't afford it.
Yeah,
it's really crazy how much it costs to
get an education.
And I understand that it's expensive to
try to give someone an education is
expensive.
Try to run you university to try it.
I mean,
people that are great teachers and
professors deserve a fair pay.
They deserve a lot of guns.
This article by David from u m in the
Atlantic atlantic.com,
uh,
he published the other day on why
colleges are so expensive and he tracks
like the number of professors that have
increased over the last 50 years,
which is,
you know,
minor,
uh,
versus the number of administrators,
deans and you know,
support a staff and so on.
If you scroll down a little bit,
uh,
let's see right there.
Uh,
so this is a in California colleges
state university system from 11,600
to 12,000
professors.
But the number of administrators went
from 3000 to 12,000
whoa.
That's the money.
Cause you know you're paying,
those are full time jobs and they all
have healthcare and benefits and
retirement and all that.
So that's where the expenses is.
Not,
not,
not in the actual teaching you have,
you have a brain,
a professor with a brain,
you know,
sending the ideas of the brains of the
students in the classroom.
It's all of the support structure around
it.
Not to mention these gyms and dorms and
cafeterias that are now nice
restaurants.
You know,
all that's expensive.
This is hilarious.
Listen to us.
Today's New York Times offers one modest
illustration.
Over the past 18 months at time reports
and 90 American colleges and
universities have hired chief diversity
officers.
These administrators who are hired in
response to the wave of racial incidents
that con convulsed convulsed campuses
like the University of Missouri over the
past year,
they are hooking up at an already
thriving industry.
Wow.
March,
2016 the National Association of
Diversity in Higher Education
held its 10th annual conference in San
Francisco.
Hilarious attendance.
Set a new record,
370 the association publishes a journal.
It bestows awards of excellence that,
that fucking thing in the University of
Missouri was a shocking insight into how
college is really working.
That lady was yelling at that student
who was a photographer who was his job
to,
he was working for this little Melissa
Click was the professor of
communications.
Yes.
Which is hilarious.
The guy was an espn reporter,
uh,
sent there to cover the protests they
were going to have and you know,
here's a professor of communication.
Say No press.
Not only that,
she asked for muscle.
That's where it got really offensive.
Like what are you a goon?
All right,
you want to bring in the gun and you see
this guy,
she comes up and knocks the camera,
but it's this,
this self righteous.
Right.
Like,
and this lack of understanding.
There she is.
Yeah.
It was a click.
It's a lack of understanding how other
people are perceiving what you're doing
and the possibility that what you're
doing is not cool at all.
Right.
But this idea of having this safe space,
like what this is college like,
what are you saying?
Like let's explore what happened here.
What was,
what was his racial incident?
And let's get to the heart of that.
Let's not get angry at some guy who's
taking a picture of things and then
photographing things like you are openly
protesting in a public place.
Right?
I would assume you want attention.
Yeah,
it does.
That's the whole point of part of it.
Right?
So this idea that you can get some guy
and hit his camera right when he's like,
this is a crazy person,
but it's a person who is,
this is,
they have too much power.
Right?
There's too much authority.
Well,
on the good side,
she was fired and appealed and lust.
So she's out.
That is good.
So that's good.
And,
and,
and sad that she got to that just in the
last two weeks,
the one of the deans at the University
of Chicago sent that letter out.
Now everyone's read it went viral.
Tall it class of 2020 no safe spaces,
no microaggressions.
We're not disadvantaging speakers.
You gotta grow up.
And um,
where I teach at Chapman University,
uh,
I sent that letter to the president and
I said,
hey,
maybe,
you know,
maybe we should do something like that.
And at first he said,
well,
I dunno,
you know,
we don't really have a problem with that
here at Chapman.
Everything's cool.
I don't want to start there.
And then he decided he'd do it.
So he did it and then they orange county
register published it.
And I thought,
this is great.
So I,
my first week of class last week to my
students,
we read it,
I said,
this is it.
There is no safe spaces here on Chapman
and so on.
You're adults now and you know,
they seem fine with that.
I think it's,
if you set up a system of sort of a
moral panic and you start looking for
any racial slurs or slights or it makes
conversation really hazardous.
Like,
Ooh,
I got to navigate around that.
I better not use,
I better be very careful.
And all of a sudden it just shuts people
down.
It becomes like Mccarthyism for
morality,
right?
You just,
you start looking for people who are
violators of it and like all these other
things that we've discussed,
there's a spectrum and there's people
that are on the extreme far fringe who
are literally recreationally outraged at
everything they see all throughout the
world without no perspective at all.
And instead of being able to look at
these things and try to see things from
other people's points of view and
perspective,
every single thing becomes a racist or
patriarchal or homophobic or
transphobic.
And there's all these different new
phrases that get abelist and fat shaming
and all these different trigger warnings
that they would like on almost every,
and it just becomes this ridiculous nerf
dup environment that you're living in.
And when you're in school and you're
preparing for the real world,
right?
If you really think that you're going to
get through school with all this
craziness about safe spaces and certain
things that trigger you and what should
be,
what should be legal and you know,
cultural appropriation,
white people shouldn't be wearing
dreadlocks and all that nonsense that
they're showing these kids.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy to assume that you can get
through that and then become a
functioning member of society and work
with 40 year old people who think you're
retarded.
Right.
I'm giving a talk next week at cal state
fullerton on this very subject because
last year the sorority got in trouble
because they held a taco Tuesday.
Yes,
I saw that cultural appropriation.
I saw that really part of it is I think
the lack of realization that,
that,
that there just are assholes in the
world.
People there are just bad,
nasty people or whatever.
The question is,
how do you deal with them?
So like a Chapman for example,
last year that the Lgbtq,
uh,
a community and a,
these are new new ones,
lgbt.
So the cue is questioning or queer.
I thought it was just queer.
Uh,
well,
no question in case you're not sure
where he shouldn't.
We have two queues just so we don't
discriminate between the poor and the
questionnaires.
That's right.
Let's make that so please people.
Let's not be insensitive.
Let's see.
I think intersectionality,
intersectionality,
I think,
have you seen between sec there?
I think that's for the biological.
You have,
you have a different genitals and you
feel like you should have or something
like that.
Have you seen pansexual?
Yes.
That that was a woman who was a
congressperson.
I think she was.
Who came out as pansexual?
Is that what she was?
No,
she wasn't a congressman.
She's a state representative,
I think.
What the fuck does she do?
She came out as pan sex.
The first pansexual politician.
Right.
What is pansexual,
man?
Again,
like it means you're,
I think it's everything.
You're a freak.
You're a little bit of Mary Gonzales,
Texas state representative identifies as
pansexual in new interview.
Oh my goodness.
Don't believe in a gender binary.
Oh yes.
That's it.
Not No gender by,
so this is called CSS,
so sexist,
Hetero Patriarchy that you,
that it's only two
men and women and that that is
discriminatory because there's people
that are in between.
I think there are.
I think there definitely are.
I think there's,
there's people that have different
levels of intelligence as people that
are shorter.
There's people that have different,
different levels of sexual desire.
There's,
and there's gotta be people that are on
the borderline between a man and a woman
and they choose to do either or.
I think of him as fuzzy sets with a
little bit of overlapping on the
borders,
right?
Most people are in one or the other.
Yes.
There are people in between.
Okay,
what do we,
what do we do?
Nothing.
You don't have to do anything.
Don't discriminate.
Yes,
of course.
You know,
you know,
don't say to an Asian person,
you must be good at math because you're
Asian or like that.
Yeah.
Don't be a dick.
But isn't that compliment?
Like if you see a black eye and he say,
you must have a big Dick because you're
a black guy,
how's he going to go?
You racist piece of shit is not right.
If you say to a guy like,
you must be a genius.
You're a,
an European cheap flight that they get
upset at you for that.
It's like that line.
And Howard Howard Stern's movie where
he,
you Jewish kid at a black high school in
Jersey and he said,
uh,
they say it's a stereotype that blacks
have bigger penises than whites and it
may be a stereotype,
but I wish I had a stereotype like that.
Anyway.
Um,
so last year I went to this little safe
space talk discussion at the Lgbtq.
I don't forget day Chatman.
Okay.
So I want your sexual,
what was the last one?
Was the a uh,
uh,
let's see.
Lgbtq a,
I forget what the analog,
it's right.
As opposed to just delete.
I have to fuck through headphones.
Okay.
What that is towards.
Um,
just the AA,
asexual,
hey intersexual asexual.
That's right.
Just and you just have no,
that's true though.
There are people that are like our sex,
so you know,
there's truth and all these things and
the people that are where there's maybe
a dozen people or so,
um,
you know,
very nice,
very thoughtful.
You know,
we,
we just like to help people.
Okay.
I feel left out and I think they should
add an h in there.
Heterosexual.
So then you can sort of see,
I can sort of see in this meeting how
the a pseudo problem becomes a problem
that isn't real.
And that is,
you know,
we're,
we're here to meet,
to discuss the problem we have.
Okay.
What's the problem?
Well,
there were some incidences against
Lgbtqa people here on campus.
Okay.
What happened?
Well,
first of all I just asked,
well,
like how many times this has happened?
Like once a day,
once a week,
once a year.
What's the rate?
Don't know.
We don't have any data.
Well,
it is it worse now as much worse?
how many times did it happen last year
or five years ago?
We don't have any data.
How do you know it's worse?
Well,
just kind of feels worse,
you know,
like we get more emails.
Okay.
That's meaningless.
Then it was like,
well,
like give me some incidences like w
examples.
What
happened?
Well,
I uh,
I heard about this gay couple.
They were walking hand in hand,
sort of on the perimeter of the campus
down the sidewalk of the local street.
And some guy in a pickup truck drove by
and made a remark.
I said that,
that's it.
Uh,
you know,
there's just,
there are assholes driving around,
you know,
it's just,
you're never,
that's never going to be zero and
there's no place you're going to go
where you're going to be safe from that
in the world.
And so the question,
how do you deal with that?
You know,
well,
you can just say fuck off asshole,
or just ignore him or you know,
whatever.
But you know,
the idea of I'm hurt,
I'm injured,
I'm damaged,
and I have to go and meet with my people
where we talk about how it hurt and
damaged.
We feel that's gonna make it worse.
I think it's going to turn,
not a non problem,
but a minuscule problem into a big
problem that doesn't need to be that
way.
That that's my opinion of that.
Well,
we're,
we're really generalizing here because
right.
We don't know what this supposedly
aggressor said.
Right.
And there's a bunch of different things
that could have said,
you know,
they could have drove by and go,
I love your hair.
And then just kept going like this piece
of shit.
He just totally gender,
right?
There's the dominoes,
That's right.
Of course there's some preposterous
recreational outrage that really,
on one hand it's what,
what is,
what's bad about it is it's indulgent
and silly.
But what's also bad about it is it
develops this cry wolf mentality where
when you see people getting offended by
things that are so fucking ridiculous,
you will almost be willing to dismiss
everything on their team.
You know,
everything that they're trying to push
forth at some of the things might have
some merit to them.
Some of the things might be really
valid,
but,
but it's all in the same camp,
right?
These ridiculous over sensitive people
that are looking to get recreational
outreach all the time.
So they might attach themselves to
really legitimate points that people
that might be more,
um,
sort of a more rigid or conservative in
their ideology.
They rejected outright.
They don't,
won't even consider it because it's
these fucking dummies.
Right.
And they're,
you know,
they're,
they're crazy outrage and there's safe
spaces like these people,
they might be attached to some really
good ideas about how,
maybe it's not a good idea to have a
bunch of guys on your campus yelling
shit out at girls as they walk by it.
And maybe we can figure out how to stop
that.
Well,
and that's right.
So all of these have little kernel of
truth and moral progress.
As I said,
it happens,
you know,
bottom up,
change language and so on.
So it starts off well intentioned that.
So the question is,
what do you do when somebody,
you know,
says something offensive,
uh,
I mean,
do we turn it into a massive campus
crisis or do you just say to the guy,
dude,
that's not cool.
Just feel,
say that kind of Shit.
It's not acceptable.
You know,
so like the,
the,
the Halloween costume incident at Yale
last year.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
the,
the faculty members sent out that email
that said,
you know,
you're adults,
we're not going to tell you what
costumes you can and cannot wear and
this erupted.
They say,
well,
what if somebody shows up in blackface?
Okay,
I'll admit,
you know,
somebody shows up in black face at a
Halloween party that's,
that's getting,
that's kind of pushing the touristic
move.
You can see your Al Jolson though,
you know,
but if you have a Mexican,
had a Sombrero,
are you dressed up as a native American?
I mean really.
I mean,
so there's sort of scales from offensive
to you inoffensive.
Well,
is it more offensive to wear black face
than it is to wear red face?
I have no idea.
But it seems to be that can,
you can kind of get away with red face
till,
right?
Uh,
well the Redskins,
you know,
probably not after we talked about this,
I'll pass some new rules.
We have to sit down,
but side,
what are you upset about it?
But why not just,
you know,
these are adults we don't need to tell,
tell them how to play in the sandbox.
Just ladies,
if your cat called,
you know,
just tell the guy shut the fuck up or
fuck off or just ignore them well and
got and tell the guy guy should be too.
You know guys,
you know you want to,
you want to get laid cat calling a woman
is,
it's going to have the opposite effect.
Now you never know.
Don't do some freaks out there and you
might call them in.
Well I call them and look at elk call.
I don't have any data on that.
I'm afraid this freaks to freak studies
out there.
They've done some studies on freaks
journal or Freak beat.
Obviously I'm joking,
but I think that when we're talking
about the difference between those films
that we watched these men beat the shit
out of women and it was like just so
standard and the outliers like when a
person does show up on campus and the
yell out sexist things,
it's like whoa.
Like,
this is an outrageous thing because it's
so rare because there has been progress,
right?
So even though I think that a lot of
people in the recreational outrage
community are outrageously stupid in
their efforts to make everything in a
offense,
I think that the pressure of all that
craziness actually somehow can probably
tone things down like the,
if the left gets so outrageous in its
demands,
the right kind of meets some somewhere
in the middle of [inaudible] get to
here,
but settle the fuck down,
right?
You know,
I'll call Caitlyn Jenner,
Kaitlin,
Katelyn,
but let's just relax on doing that to
six year olds.
You know,
it's like,
let's figure out a comfortable medium.
And then in becoming more and more
tolerant as time goes on,
it'll just be the norm.
Just like slapping people in those
movies was normal in 1960.
But in today,
it's outrageous.
And in a television show,
like to the moon,
alice,
if you had a new guy,
you know,
like the,
um,
you know,
some Kevin James,
Kevin James is in some new sitcom.
We threatened to beat the shit out of
his wife,
right?
Like,
Whoa,
how long would that show stay on the
air?
There's been progress made.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So I think,
you know,
people getting outrageously upset about
things that merit being outrageously
upset.
It makes everybody think,
but when people were outrageously upset
about someone having a fucking Taco
Tuesday,
right?
You know,
or trying to cut some white dudes
dreadlocks off like,
okay,
you're losing me here,
you're going too far going too far the
other way.
You're not reasonable.
Right?
You look at and get pissed off over
nonsense.
Like there's things to be like,
you hear about that kid who got away
with raping some girl and he was,
the girl had been passed out and he only
got six months and now that six months,
that is something to be erased.
That's a real scary thing.
But you should be really pissed off
about not Taco fucking Tuesday.
Right?
So there,
I think that hurts the cause of real
injustices that need to be corrected.
Then they get lumped in with the silly
stuff and it's not.
So we have to get away from binary
thinking to scale thinking,
yes,
you know,
it's a spectrum.
And choosing gender teams too.
It becomes a real issue because there's
pieces of shit on the male side and
there's really fucking questionable
people in the female side too.
Right?
Like that mattress girl thing.
All right.
You know where this Columbia,
you guys suing the school now she
collected her diploma with a mattress
and we don't know what happened because
we weren't there,
but there's some crazy texts exchanged
back and forth where she's asking him to
come over and find her in the ass or
something.
Is that what she said?
Did I make that up?
Allegedly find that out.
I don't want to get sued.
Super important that you be real clear.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but if it really is something like that.
What was the,
uh,
the false rape accusation that made it
to the New York Times or excuse me,
a rolling stone.
The Rolling Stone,
was it Virginia?
Yeah.
I mean that is crazy.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And when something gets to the point
where it's in rolling stone,
it's a complete total fabrication like
that where somebody just made something
up and it didn't go through the proper
channels because everything with dealing
with gender and all these issues that
are super sensitive issues gets treated
with kid gloves instead of approaching
it with the same kind of skepticism,
they would up murder case or a case of
theft.
Instead it gets immediately looked at
like there's one possible scenario here.
This woman has been victimized to
question her would be horrific.
Right?
And you shouldn't even observe the
facts.
He shouldn't even have an open mind.
You have to go into it with this,
even though you really don't have any
information really whatsoever other than
people talking,
right.
You have to go into it with this idea
that this person talking,
he's telling you the truth.
Right?
Otherwise you're blaming the victim.
I mean,
he's shocked.
Fuck me in the butt.
Thank you.
I got nervous.
She said bluntly during one facebook
exchange.
See,
I don't know what happened between them.
And if someone sends you a text like
that,
it doesn't mean that you're allowed to
rape them,
but his version of what happened versus
her version would happen.
You don't know who's telling the truth.
You just don't know.
And when,
when things get so outrageous that this
rolling stone thing gets published and
gets treated with kid gloves and one of
the most important magazines in American
crusher,
right,
treats this as if it's a real story and
it turns out to be a complete
fabrication.
It's sort of in some ways highlights the
problems with dealing with this kind of
stuff in a non objective way.
Carol tavers wrote a nice piece for us
and skeptic on,
uh,
what you,
what we mean when we
talk about rape and it gets his
categorical binary thinking.
So there's perfect behavior and
everything else is rape.
And so she talks about,
you know,
the dance of seduction and you know,
the guy's pressing and you know,
she's saying no.
And then he says,
okay.
Then she kind of hints that maybe okay,
a little bit more.
And then you just sort of,
you know,
the whole foreplay process is kind of a
way of ending up over here and yes,
absolutely.
Whenever she says no,
then that's it.
It's no,
but it isn't like,
you know,
she said no,
uh,
when they were still at the restaurant
and he just raped her anyway.
Usually if there's a whole series of
steps that we never get to see or no one
knows we weren't there,
we don't know what happened and what the
gray area was.
And when she says no,
but no for now,
maybe later.
And none of that gets recorded.
So we have no idea of what happened.
Well,
we also have to consider the,
like we've been talking about with so
many different other examples that there
is a giant spectrum of people's
behavior.
There are men that I know that liked to
get bossed around by women and smacked
around and they like them to do terrible
things to them.
And they will pay these women to do
this.
They'll go to a dominatrix or this woman
will insult them and hit them.
She beats them and paddles them.
They do all kinds of crazy stuff to
them.
And a lot of these guys were like
wealthy guys who have,
you know,
they have like high pressure careers and
I've met,
these guys have talked to him.
I've know guys that have had this thing,
but if it's the other way,
if it's a woman that likes getting
smacked around by a guy,
then it becomes a crutch.
Like you don't even want to know that
that girl is,
it exists,
right?
Like,
well,
a woman can't hire a male dominate years
to kick her ass and raper.
But a man can hire a woman to humiliate
or Piss on her.
Like I know this guy likes girls to piss
on him.
He's crazy.
Jim Norton,
he's a wild man,
but he talks about it openly.
He's a comedian,
but he's not the high,
high pressure,
you know,
executive type ties are doing it.
He's just a nut and a pervert.
But hilarious,
hilarious comedian.
But it's okay.
I mean,
he doesn't like it and beat up,
but it's,
it's okay.
Like you can,
you can be a man and you can hire some
women to kick your ass and you could
have this desire to have this happen to
you,
but we're supposed to pretend that
there's not some women out there who
doesn't want to like engage in a similar
type of activity with a man and they
must exist.
They just do.
They just do,
right?
They must and if is it the same if you
decide that you and you're the person
that you have sex with,
if you guys decide that you,
this is the way you do things,
you,
you decide that she likes to smack you
around and she likes to get on top of
you and you get off on it and she tells
you when you're going to have sex.
No,
now mother fucker we're going to,
and you're like,
oh,
and you got to give into it.
This is this weird game that you guys
play that is completely fine.
But if the roles are reversed,
right,
and you do that to her and you guys both
get off on it,
it's a terrible crime.
And it's interesting.
It's interesting because it's not,
we're not talking grape,
we're knocking down.
We're not talking being prorate in any
way,
shape or form or pro domestic violence.
We're talking about people like Weird
Shit,
right?
And some people actually want you to
commit crimes to them.
Well,
imagine a scenario in which that was all
consensual.
And then six months later he published
his story in rolling stone saying,
I never consented.
She beat me.
Yeah.
Reverse those roles it looks like.
Right?
It sounds terrible,
but you don't know what all the steps
where there's a great little short film.
It's like fun.
Sounds like rape,
apology talk though.
You know that Rhino,
even discussing this,
you become a rape apologist,
right?
So we should like be really clear.
That's not what I am doing.
I'm looking at all the possibilities of
human behavior and I'm saying people are
fucking weird.
We're weird.
You know?
And our,
our ideals,
a lot of times they're shaped by popular
culture and they're shaped by songs and
movies.
And those in some ways dictate more of
what we expect from our life than the
actual lives we see around us.
Right?
As each people are fucking strange.
They're fucking strange.
So this,
this new law in California,
you have to have verbal consents.
How do you know?
Unless you record it?
Yeah,
it's still,
he said,
she said,
well,
I asked her verbally,
she said yes.
And then she says,
I never said yes.
How do we know?
Did you see the video that got released
with this really wealthy billionaire
character in Florida filmed his
girlfriend beating herself up?
She's on the bed and he put in a
security camera because,
I don't know,
maybe he just knew she was gonna do
something crazy like this.
So he's breaking up with her.
And uh,
she told the police,
he beat her up.
She's on the bed,
whaling herself in the face,
and there's video this screaming at the
top of her lungs were weighing yourself
into a frenzy,
probably with the windows open so the
neighbors can hear it.
And she's just beating the shit out of
herself.
So what does,
he didn't have video.
He'd be screwed.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And many people have been for sure.
I mean,
this is not,
again,
this is not being a domestic violence
apologist.
This is not saying that men don't beat
women.
It's just saying when we look at things,
as you know,
I'm a man so I side with all men,
or I'm a woman.
So the women must be telling the truth
when they're just people.
There's awesome people that are men.
There's awesome people that are women.
There's awesome people that are asexual.
It just does a really good,
a really good little film short online.
I can't remember the producer.
It might've been right,
man.
Is there a reitman producer?
Uh,
yeah,
Ivan Reitman is,
maybe that was it.
Anyway,
it's a young couple,
like in a dorm room and they're on the
bed clothes on.
They're making out in foreplay and at
some point he says,
you know,
I think I,
I better get the,
you know the thing.
And she goes,
yeah,
I think you should.
And you're thinking he's going to reach
for a condom.
And he pulls a contract out and he's
like,
all right,
so,
and then he,
and then his lawyer comes in and then
her lawyer has it and they're like,
okay,
my client would like to touch your
client on the breasts.
Now will your client agreed to this?
Okay.
So he checked this and the whole thing
goes through that.
Yeah.
It's called consents made by his son
Jason Reitman.
Oh,
that's it.
there we go.
Yeah,
there's a hilarious one that was a pro
consent video that they had released,
tried to get people acclimated with this
idea.
And it's a attractive young couple like
hipster looking dude.
He had like a funky mustache and his,
he's with a girl and they're making out
and he's like,
can I touch your leg?
And she's like,
yes.
And uh,
and then she's like,
can I touch your leg?
And he's like,
yes.
can I kiss you?
And she says,
yes.
And he goes,
can I take your shirt off?
She goes,
not yet.
And they keep making out and it's,
it's Kinda hot.
It's Kinda hot.
Like,
I don't think you should fucking have to
do that all the time.
And especially if you're in a
relationship with someone,
then it's ridiculous.
And I could understand like the first
couple of times you do it,
but the video,
like I don't,
I don't support that being a rule.
But if two people want to do that on
their own,
that video is kind of hot.
Like it looks like wow.
Eventually she said no and then she said
yes,
the shirt came off.
We're making progress.
Some things are happening.
She's,
she's obviously enjoying this makeout
thing.
Like it's Kinda hot,
but you shouldn't fucking have to do
that.
Most people have never done that.
And this idea that you make it a law and
then you got to enforce it.
How do you enforce the law?
And it's not going to work with
everybody.
Some people don't want to say Shit,
some women don't want to talk about it.
Some men don't want to talk about it.
And some people want to talk about every
single aspect of it.
Right.
Find someone who meshes with what the
look,
he gave an interview.
I think it might've been enrolling
stuff.
No,
it might've been in the Atlantic where
it Kinda college coed and the guy just
kept asking her an African,
I did that.
She said shut the fuck up and just fuck
me.
I'm on.
Well that's,
you know,
I mean that's okay too.
Right?
It's like everything's okay,
but as soon as you start telling people,
you've got to ask every question in the
book before you do it.
No you don't.
No,
you just don't rape people.
Right.
Just don't rate people and then we're
all good.
All right.
It's real simple.
Don't hold anybody down.
Don't make them do things.
Don't fuck them when they're passed out,
we are done.
Yeah.
It's just,
it gets,
it gets a little silly,
but you know,
the intention behind it is like you're
saying,
the intention behind it ultimately is
about progress.
Ultimately is about making an
environment,
whether it's ill intentioned or not,
or whether it's like ill thought out or
not.
The idea is to create a safer
environment.
It's just,
are you doing that or are you just
annoying the fuck out of people?
And the same amount of sexual assault
was going to go on it.
I don't know.
Right.
It's an interesting question because if
you pull so far left,
do they meet in a different place then
they would be if he just let them,
well boys will be boys stay away from
the fraternity ladies.
You know what I mean?
That doesn't fly anymore.
So maybe it does in some way help and
then,
you know,
we set,
we put up with the number of diversity
officers.
I mean the moment you hire somebody
whose job it is to basically look for
diversity anytime it doesn't meet what,
you know,
whatever the criteria is at that moment
it's like,
okay,
we have a problem.
Yeah.
Okay.
Did we really have a problem?
Maybe a little bit,
but now it's a big official problem.
You gotta write it up.
We got to make it a law.
You know,
betty work.
Yeah.
Busy work looking and then they're
looking for trouble.
Like unions had been doing that since
the beginning of time.
That's teachers' unions.
I mean that's like a,
that's a big issue.
They've been creating jobs since the
beginning of the time.
That was always like that.
I had a buddy of mine who had a job on,
um,
what does that,
where they do the big g,
the javits center,
you know,
the javits center in New York.
He had a job where he doesn't even go
there.
He got a check every week.
He didn't even go there.
He never went there.
And he was one of those no show jobs.
Right?
He's like some union deal that they had
made probably with quote unquote
organized crime and this,
so all that stuff's always been fluffed
up forever.
So this idea of having all these
diversity officers,
they're going to fucking create conflict
just to keep their job afloat.
The last thing they want is them to be
obsolete.
You know,
we'll look,
we all just decided like taco Tuesday's
good.
I like Tacos and a,
yeah,
you can dress like an Indian if you
really love native Americans.
I mean,
do you really have a respect for it?
And you're not like being an asshole
about it.
Right.
Okay,
cool.
The black face,
we're going to leave that alone.
We're not going to go with black face.
But that's,
that's why the only way the rule is
don't be a deck.
And,
and most people know when they're being
a dick and if they don't,
then then your,
your colleagues,
a friend should tell you,
but can you be a dick?
And be funny,
like,
okay,
like you can as a comedian,
I can't,
but if a white guy,
like what if a black guy dresses like a
white guy,
puts white face on and just starts doing
the most ridiculous white stereotype?
Well,
I remember when,
um,
uh,
ted Danson came was on,
was it the Oscars or the analyzer with a
penalty?
We had any host or something.
Right?
He was dating her at the time and he
made a little joke about we'll
chamberlains record and he showed up a
leg face.
Remember that?
That was,
uh,
yeah,
he got,
that was a big controversy.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
you know,
at this point,
whenever that place,
it's like a bronze,
1980s,
I think,
you know what I mean?
That is hilarious that he did that no
longer funny.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy though?
That this is one specific look with
makeup,
we do not allow,
you cannot pretend to be a white person
who are,
you cannot be a white person who's
pretending to be a black person,
but you can pretend to be anything else.
Right?
Like a white man can pretend there's,
it's probably good reasons for that in
our history.
Well,
who the fuck was,
um,
who played Charlie Chan?
It was a white guy,
right?
The famous Chinese detective that was a
white guy.
And we,
when John Wayne played gingiss con and
remember that it didn't Tom Cruise play
an Asian and one of the things,
he was the last Samurai,
but he was a Europe.
That's good.
Yeah,
that's good.
No,
man,
it's,
it's interesting.
And I get it.
There was slavery and take 200 years
ago.
I get,
I understand the whole thing.
It's,
it's still quite odd,
you know?
And when a black person puts on
whiteface and pretends to be a white
person,
no one gives up.
Fuck.
Here we go.
Right?
Warner.
Oh land is Charlie Chan.
That is the most non Chinese.
He looks totally Puerto Rican.
It was mustache.
What nationality was that guy?
Did he have some weird,
uh,
stuff that they put on his face?
Let's find out what a nationality is.
If you had to guess,
what do you say?
I say maybe he's got a little native
American and I'm Swedish.
Oh God.
More let's practically native American
US practically Chinese.
You're not close to anything.
He's so white.
That's like the widest race.
He could pick like what's more white
than Swedish people.
That's the widest,
every Swedish meatballs and shit.
The Swiss chocolate,
Switzerland,
it's different country,
but that's really white for him to
believe.
Charlie chance generating this just
started reading this book on audio,
the for the 50 year mission sort of oral
history of Star Trek.
Oh Wow.
So they start with a alert.
Oh yeah,
totally,
totally.
Uh,
but uh,
you know,
the actors,
a black,
Asian and so forth,
they actually got to play a real black
eye,
real Asian in a real job.
And that was,
you know,
1966 that was pretty innovative at the
time.
It's really important that the guy that
played Sulu,
what's his name?
Um,
uh,
George's church.
Kay.
You know,
Japanese and all.
He was talking to this oral history
about what kind of kinds of jobs he had
before star Trek,
which,
you know,
you played the sort of obnoxious,
the servant or the obnoxious agent Asian
or whatever,
but never like an actual real job where
you're having an important position.
George C K,
uh,
lived in an internment camp.
Yeah.
Right.
Yup.
It's terrifying.
Yeah.
That's,
that's how recently that was.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
roddenberry was something of a visionary
in that sense.
A little bit ahead of his time on that
too.
That shows awesome.
Yeah.
Even to this day,
it's hit that corny place like a,
I watched one where a captain kirk has
to fight that Lizard Dude with the
shitty outfit on that is like,
that was done right here at Vasquez
rocks right up off of 14.
You can go there and you can see where
captain kirk pushed him off like near to
Panga like that way?
No,
no.
Uh,
Vasquez Rosecrance is run off of highway
14 so he takes highway 14 so you take
five north 14 that goes up to Lancaster.
Palmdale.
Oh,
okay.
We out there and we did a lot of,
of all those westerns were shot out
there.
We did a lot of fear factor stuff out
Oh right.
Oh that's so pretty.
Oh wow man.
That is beautiful.
Yeah.
So that's where that is.
It's all in your plan down here.
You watched this video.
This is awesome.
Awesome.
This guy who's playing the lizard guy is
so bad.
Like everything is so bad.
The outfits so bad.
The movement so bad.
Like look how slow this is.
Look,
I was thinking this is fucking
incredibly bad.
He swings.
Look at this.
He's not in slow motion.
This is how the show is really playing
out.
Look how slow this is.
Look,
he throws a kick.
Oh,
Captain Kirk,
let him catch a kick.
That's good.
That's bad.
Moy,
Tai,
he supposed to kick the leg out.
You don't throw the guy in the air like
that.
And if you definitely throw them in the
eye,
you follow up.
Where's your ground and pound?
Bitch.
Okay,
look at this.
How come the lizard so much now he's got
to do the helmet.
Slap the eardrums.
Oh right.
Look at this.
He's trying to bite him.
Look how bad this is.
My God.
This is amazingly bad.
But when you're 10 years old,
this is really,
really high drama.
Oh,
it was incredible back then.
Look,
he does.
He does the double ear smack in the
Lizard,
can handle it,
and then he runs away like the slowest
white guy that's ever walked the face of
the earth.
I mean,
this is so stupid hair.
He's got this Styrofoam Styrofoam Rock
and watch how it looks fake to like even
when he's picking it up,
but he's not even straining.
Look how weaknesses.
He throws it,
boom,
and it hits them right in the chest.
Nothing.
Sorry,
I can't believe this.
Me Ma.
Go back to hitting him in the year,
motherfucker.
You hit him in the ear.
There's hurt.
There's another video that was just
released a few weeks ago of Shatner and
the lizard monster on,
on his couch and they're watching a TV
show or something and they start
fighting.
He keep the thing playing cause I want
to find out how this ends.
That's really stupid.
It wasn't the,
oh it doesn't end until uh,
he,
he makes gunpowder and shoots him.
Alright boy.
Talk about giving a guy a lot of room.
Look that he threw a big giant rock out
of it.
It looks so fake.
This lizard all of a sudden is so strong
that he could take a 500 pound rock and
throw it like it's basketball.
But just a few minutes ago he was
struggling with weak ass.
Captain Kirk is ending a technique.
Look,
you hit him in the ear,
you did some serious damage and you let
that go and start throwing rocks.
Go back to hitting him in the fucking
ear.
Just go whack them in the ear.
It seems to be as a soft spot.
Keep doing that.
But then it the show shoal and before
the 48 minutes is out,
they'll find it.
It's just the look so hilarious.
How slow that thing was moving.
It was worse than I thought it was.
See that's,
that's also that is there.
Oh look at this same technique.
Look,
that's hilarious.
All of themselves.
Oh well they're both.
That is hilarious.
He's going after we get,
that's hilarious.
This is really funny.
Let me chat and he's got a good sense
of,
yeah,
there's two that you're going to send up
of himself,
but that is that show and that that
scene,
it shows in a lot of ways how far our
entertainment is evolved.
I mean that is,
that's a comedy today.
Look,
if you had that on comedy central,
right?
If you had to like ridiculous space
show,
if you call it ridiculous space show and
you essentially just have a lot of the
same shit that was in regular space
movie,
just reenact them,
laugh.
They would laugh.
You have the right lines that went along
with how stupid that looks yet.
Well,
like Mike Myers send son all the spy
movies.
Right.
But if you watch like a science fiction
movie today,
like if you ever seen that Netflix show
stranger things,
I just got into it a motto for five
episodes into it.
It's fucking great.
Brian Redman told me it was bad.
He's crazy.
It's really good.
It's stranger things on Netflix.
It's with a homegirl that's steal shit.
Winona Ryder,
she's,
oh no that's bad.
She's awesome.
And a two and Matthew Modine,
the guy from vision quest,
he's in it.
It's really good.
Really good show fallen training.
This oral history though.
It,
you know,
cause I had just had these fond memories
when I was 12 years old,
11 that show and now I get,
well shatner wanted more money and then
when Nimo I became famous,
he got pissed and we started cutting his
lines and then the Neem I wanted to
raise and it's like I don't really want
to know.
I should keep that shit to themselves.
And that's probably pretty common with
any business.
I suppose the wind screech wrote that
book about saved by the Bell.
I was crushed.
It was that inside mma or no screech
saved by the bell.
You know what to say by the bells.
It was a ridiculous children's sitcoms.
It wasn't on Nickelodeon.
Is that what it was?
It was on t NBC.
NBC.
What was that Saturday morning,
Oh,
huge show though.
You'd show amongst the little kids and
one of them are rebelled and became a,
he did porn,
wrote books,
got in a knife fight,
gotten a knife,
fight.
Celebrity boxing.
If somebody beat the shit out of him.
Right.
It didn't,
uh,
Danny Bonaduce,
he beat the shit out of him,
right?
No,
he beat you up.
Welcome back Kotter.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's agreed to go to jail.
I thought he went to jail too.
He stabbed somebody,
didn't he?
Yeah,
like literally stab time the bell.
Okay.
He's crazy.
And so he wrote an autobiography saying
that,
um,
tiffany ever thiess and was banging
everybody boxing Mario Lopez,
Bang and everybody.
Well,
I'm like,
yeah,
Duh.
It's Mario Lopez.
But I was in a minute,
here we go.
Mario wrote,
he wrote that,
that Mario Lopez telling even read that
I liked Mario.
I was in a pitch meeting one time at
Fox,
um,
flux reality.
Mike Darnell was their big reality show
guy.
He's the one that brought,
um,
uh,
all the big American idol show type
shows,
including American idol.
Anyway,
we were pitching a skeptic show,
so I had a production company and
myself,
and we had our waiting in the little
room for him to be done with this
meeting and he came out to apologize
that he was late because,
um,
they were supposed to have a big
celebrity boxing match that night.
Uh,
Paula Jones versus Tonya harding.
Oh,
Jesus.
And Tonya Hardy.
He got arrested that day for beating her
boyfriend up with a hubcap and their
trailer park or something.
And I remember sitting there thinking,
what am I doing here?
You know,
I mean,
Tin Paula Jones went up doing like
penthouse or something crazy that she
do.
Didn't she do one of those?
Well,
she did celebrity boxing.
They anything.
Yeah,
there we go.
Tonya harding did.
Is that Paula Jones?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
there it is.
Paula Jones is the woman who accused
Bill Clinton of doing dirty things to
her.
Yeah.
Paula,
I'm not.
Paul Jones saw Tonya harding box.
Doug.
Stan hope on the man show.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We had a boxing match when Tonya harding
became a boxer for a while,
I remember.
Right.
Yeah.
She was doing like,
maybe this was her start and yeah,
she was just,
she's nice.
I met her.
She's a nice person.
Right.
She's just desperate for money.
Yeah.
Like an ice skater there.
She's thick.
Oh,
she must have been a good athlete to,
I mean,
you can't be an Olympic ice skater.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
Good athlete.
She was,
but that was a weird view into
athletics.
Right.
When a Nancy Kerrigan is got beaten up
by that,
he hit her in the legs.
Right.
Like hit her in the leg with a stick or
something like that.
So guy like a tire iron.
Was it a tyrant?
He bashed?
He,
I think he shattered her.
Not The kneecap,
but right next to it or part of it or
correct it or something.
Yeah,
it was pretty heavy.
I thought she was able to command it
was,
I think it was Tonya harding boyfriend
had hired the guy,
so she,
she was indirectly involved.
Right.
Yeah.
And,
um,
they were planning on Tonya harding
winning the Olympics.
Right.
They wanted her to,
she,
it was her and um,
and uh,
Nancy Kerrigan,
they were the golden middle toe to
compete competition for the gold medal.
Yeah.
I don't remember the extent of the
injury.
I remember Nancy Kerrigan was screaming
and she was holding like there was a
video of it,
right?
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
But she came back.
There's a video.
Was there a video of the guy doing it?
I don't think so.
I think that it's got this aftermath
part.
She's screaming.
She ended up competing in those
Olympics.
I think that is so crazy that someone
could do that.
Just run up to this girl and smash or
with a tire iron.
Is that what it was?
What is it?
What he was trying to think.
So fuck.
That is so crazy.
That's so crazy that someone could do
that because of an ice skating
competition that instead of competing
and trying to win and trying to be the
best,
you hire someone as smash,
excuse me,
collapsible baton.
Oh,
so it was one of those buttons that they
use for that ex husband,
her ex husband,
Shane.
Stan had been hired by her ex touching.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's what Michael said.
That's crazy.
Tell us those things.
She was never convicted of being
associated with it at all.
It was just indirectly anyway.
Well,
how could,
you know what,
what words were said right,
but crazy that someone would do that for
an ice skating competition.
You smashed some girl's leg.
That's it's,
but again,
isn't there a Texas cheerleader mom that
attack the other moms daughter who was
competing with her daughter for the
cheerleader that where there was even a
few years ago,
maybe even killed her or just attacked
her brutally or something like that.
Uh,
you might,
yeah.
Texas cheerleader.
Murdery mom.
Yeah,
that's it.
Oh my God.
Nine.
It's like a lifetime movie story kind of
thing.
Yeah.
Oh,
but it's real.
It's based on real sure.
Yeah.
They add a few things to those based on
rails.
I was devastated when I found out the
revenant.
The revenant wasn't real.
Oh,
really?
Oh my God.
Not only was it not real and apparently
they don't even say it's real,
but everybody says it's real everybody.
Cause I,
I had heard the story before for my
friend Steve Rinella,
who was a,
like a,
he's really kind of a historian on the
wild west.
Get some great stories about the
conflicts that she need of Americans and
settlers.
He knows all about the pioneers of the
mountain men.
He said that that guy,
first of all,
the guy in that Leonardo Dicaprio played
never had a son.
That was one of the main motivations of
him going after this guy that got
killed.
His son didn't have a son.
Uh,
the only thing that was true was he got
attacked by a bear and they left him to
dad and he survived.
But he didn't kill anybody.
But there really were killing people and
survive in and the guy never killed
anybody.
There really were a trappers and there
really were native Americans and they
really were bears.
Yes.
All those things existed.
So it's so funny when you have a movie,
like then you put words in people's
mouths and you just decide what they
could've said that sounded cool.
Like they shouldn't be allowed to do
that.
You know,
based on means we're gonna make some
shit up.
Right?
Like you could Kevin Costner,
you could do dances with wolves cause
you got to fake character.
But you know,
when you did Wyatt earp,
you made a bunch of shit up,
right?
He decided what Wyatt earp said,
how do you know we don't have a
recording?
No,
it's all historical.
Recreation's like that.
It's very strange.
All right,
sir.
Did we hit the wall?
What?
Michael Shermer?
Yeah,
it's three hours and 20 minutes,
somewhere around.
I know that's not the record,
but uh,
I know your bladder is ready to give
out,
but there's that.
There's that.
Thank you,
man.
Well listen,
let everybody know where they can get
ahold of you,
where it can read your work,
where they could a skeptic.com
or Michael Shermer.
DICOM is,
you know,
the best place.
You're the first guy to ever tapped out
like that too.
And you're like,
that's it.
Oh No,
really?
We're done talking.
I can't.
Alright.
I appreciate it.
I was ready to wrap it up.
I've got a dinner to go to you.
I understand.
Yeah.
Um,
so thank you very much.
It's always awesome talking to you.
I really do appreciate it.
And anytime you want to do it,
that's really,
thank you very much.
Thanks everybody.
See You tomorrow.
Bye.
Dan.
Carlin's going to be on tomorrow.
Oh,
wow.
Really?
Oh,
cool.